test one two
all right one minute till we start the
hearing
good morning it being 10 o'clock I will
open the hearing on House Bill 311 call
on one of the sponsors representative
emmerich
thank you Mr chair my name is Tracy
Emrick I represent Hampton which is
Rockingham District 29. I'm here uh for
Tom Buco who was the primary sponsor he
was afraid he was going to be snowed in
I don't know if he is or not in Conway
but
he decided I said well if you can't make
it I'll be glad to do it for you
what this bill is is basically a belt
and a suspenders
when I came on finance my first year Tom
Buco introduced a bill very similar to
this and he did every turn every year
for six years and in division one we
started referring to it as Buco bucks
because it was he was like a recurring
nightmare with these with this
ultimately what was happening is uh
payments were coming delayed from the
state and so what Tom did is he wanted
to put it in a bill to make sure the
payments were made in a timely fashion
my understanding is now we're up to date
so he still wants to have the suspenders
in a belt to have legislation that says
yes you will pay in a timely fashion
those things which the state owes cities
and towns that's what this is it's uh
two years 15 million dollars you can see
in the fiscal note that one year it's
looks like this would be a little too
much in another year it looks like it'd
be a little too little but that that's
basically what the Bill's about is so
cities and towns in their wastewater
treatment
updates uh can be compensated in a
timely manner
and I just told you all I know but I'll
be glad to try to answer questions even
though I I'll look like a deer in a
headlights
representative McGuire is recognized for
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative when you say this is
Belton suspenders do you mean to say
that somehow this money is in the budget
twice or this bill plus it's in the
budget or something like that
yes
it is this this these monies are
budgeted by Des as part of their budget
what this does is make sure that they'll
expend it
because in the past years while even
though it was budgeted it was not
expended it didn't forward the funds to
the cities and towns for whatever reason
and all this is is
I'll call it insurance policy it sounds
less dramatic
so so if this passes it doesn't mean
they'll spend twice as much on this item
correct all right thank you
there's a representative Miller for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking a question in um in
reading the language of the bill it
doesn't seem to require it to be spent
it just appropriates it so I'm just not
sure how it achieves the goal that you
described which is to make the
department make the payments and you
know do all that I didn't write the bill
I I I I'll have to defer to people who
are smarter with this than I am we'll
catch on it later thank you thank you Mr
chair
any further questions from the committee
members seeing none thank you
representative Emrick
we'll next call on representative excuse
me Mr Boyd Smith from New Hampshire
Water Works Association
uh good morning chairman Weiler and uh
thanks for the time and good morning to
the committee members my name is Boyd
Smith I'm the director of the New
Hampshire Water Works Association and
what we do is represent over 300
members that provide drinking water most
public drinking water in the state of
New Hampshire we're in support of this
piece of legislation although I realize
it's it sounds like there's still some
questions around it that uh I may not be
able to answer but um we're in support
of it because a number of our our
systems a lot of systems in New
Hampshire have both clean water uh
provision and they also treat waste
water this particular bill as I
understand it
is a commitment from the state
or honoring a commitment from the state
under an existing statute to be part of
the funding mix for municipalities that
are building Wastewater systems as
approved basically by nhdes
you probably know there's a number of
sources for funding these big projects
they're very expensive multi-million
dollars multiple years
and you know we usually get big boosts
from the federal government to do
Capital Improvement on infrastructure it
hasn't happened for 40 years but it's
happening now you know with the the arpa
money and the bil money so we've got a
big influx of cash from the feds to
update infrastructure that much of it's
four decades old and it's past the point
of failure as you can imagine we can't
afford to have our waste water and
drinking water systems fail
so this piece of funding from uh that's
being requested in this bill is uh part
of as I understand it a promise from an
irsa I think it's 486 it's been in place
for a long time
and that that calls for the state to you
know to be a part of the funding source
and this 15 million dollars uh per year
roughly that you're looking at is a
number that's been pretty well
calculated based on need of projects
approved by Des and again there's
smarter people than I could get into
those details if you want but it's a
well-justified need following a process
that that Des uses for uh you know most
federal funding the srf and Etc
and it helps it helps towns pay off you
know that carry their debt so imagine
you know most of our municipalities are
towns they've got a town meeting you
know they meet in March there's a
warrant article for a bond to you know
to borrow whatever three million dollars
five million dollars for a necessary
infrastructure project they figure that
they're going to get 15 you know sorry
about 20 percent assistance from the
state on their principle and and loan to
manage their debt and then they don't
see it and my understanding is it's not
so much a timing thing or a des thing
it's been an it's been a budgetary
allocation that some years it gets
allocated some years it doesn't
um so having a Dependable source of
funds
helps towns to talk to their citizens
and say you know get ready we're going
to pick up a bond for 20 years for
something that we all count on but we
pretty much take for granted and don't
understand
um
so I think you all know uh that uh this
is important to have we need toilets
that flush somewhere we need drinking
water that comes out clean I think a
regular this this 15 million dollar that
proposed my understanding is as a
baseline moving forward you know like as
is Promised in the statute is a a very
helpful meaningful and we hope
reasonable balance of the state's
commitment
to the towns it's it's money well spent
so um thank you very much for the time
I'll answer any questions you have if I
can and if I can't I'll get back to you
as soon as possible with answers
questions from the committee members
seeing none I have one these things that
have been added recently like pfast
what sort of equipment has to be added
to all these places that already had
water treatment plants does this bring
on a whole new set of equipment that has
to be added or what what sort of
mechanical stuff is added here yeah
that's a great question and and frankly
the drinking water and wastewater people
uh in New Hampshire and anywhere
impacted by pfas are really scratching
their heads over it it the short answer
is it's going to be more money under the
current standards we're just New
Hampshire has drinking water standards
for pfas we're anticipating even tighter
standards to be proposed by EPA you know
soon
challenge with Wastewater is we're still
working on analytical test methods to
deter you know to to find out what the
concentrations are and then you have to
determine how much uh in say biosolage
residuals
um is too much to prevent leaching uh
into the ground or wherever you dump it
because you have to have a place to dump
it so we're dealing with what do you do
with uh you know these waste streams so
to get the short answer is it's going to
be complicated we don't have all the
answers now and it's absolutely going to
cost much more money to deal with pfas
the way it's evolving now is it possible
that the equipment hasn't even been
developed that can get to the
ridiculously low level that they have
set on this
I I don't know I mean my experience is
if you've got enough money you can
pretty much fix everything but uh I I'm
not familiar with the technology uh that
that would do that I thought maybe
that's where your expertise layer no I'm
a groundwater Lake water drinking water
kind of guy yeah all right
further questions from the committee
representative papovichi Muller thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking
our questions
basically the way you describe it the
purpose of this bill is to help towns
afford you know projects that may not
otherwise have afforded by you know
having other
State residents sharing to the cost of
it could you explain a little bit more
why we need to bring funds from other
towns who don't benefit from those Works
to help the towns that do sure yeah
that's a great question I'm sure it
comes up all the time you know you hear
a local issue and then what's the
benefit
um I I think
I'll take a shot at this I mean that's a
good question for our Economist
um we are small uh towns scattered all
over the state
but we are interdependent
um you know people move they live in one
town they work in another if they have
any kind of a tourist base folks are
coming in to you know to stay out of
town a b and b a restaurant you know
open a business we move around we're not
Islands within you know within our state
borders and
at some point I guess this is kind of
the question about what's the purpose of
government you know at what point do you
um you know uh take from some people to
give to others I would say when you're
dealing with drinking water and waste
water which is what this bill's talking
about waste water that it truly is a
universal issue and it's also I think
it's like the type of projects that um
you know they're too big you see someone
might need a system and we see a lot of
very very small systems in New Hampshire
that have they can't afford to do any of
this stuff so
um on the drinking water side there's
over 2000 regulated systems only 50
serve more than 3 000 people you know so
50 of them serve I don't know 50 of the
state population the other two thousand
the other you know four percent that's
covered so I I think it's a fill in some
ways a philosophical but I think there's
strong economic reasons to invest in the
quality of drinking water and wastewater
everywhere there's a facility being
operated thank you
further questions from committee members
seeing none thank you Mr Boyd thank you
very much for your time and I apologize
for Miss uh addressing my testimony
letter to you I got ahead of myself a
little bit and I'm kind of new at the
game everybody now has a copy okay good
thank you sir
it's in the streets
the next call upon Catherine Heck from
nhma
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Catherine heck
and I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal Association the cities and
towns here in New Hampshire and I don't
want to repeat any testimony that you've
already heard as to why these dollars
are important and we continue our
partnership with the state I would like
to add however that as we're looking at
things like expanding housing and
housing availability access to public
water and sewer become a very critical
part of that expansion
um into the housing area so we do know
anecdotally that an upgrade to a major
sewer system can be 20 to 40 million
dollars we do know that a mile a pipe is
1.2 to 1.4 million dollars for water and
sewer pipe so these are huge expenses so
as we're thinking about the housing
crisis that we're experiencing and we
want municipalities to be able to expand
the ability to build affordable homes in
New Hampshire we have to consider the
access for the smaller lots to have on
public water and sewer so I certainly
can take any questions that you might
have but I didn't want to repeat what
was already said thank you
thank you questions from committee
members
representative papavichi Miller thank
you Mr chairman and thanks Mrs hack for
taking the questions different questions
since you brought up housing
availability
would you see a need to you know
subsidize those things for just for the
benefits to housing or are there any
other other reasons because I can think
of a lot of towns that water or not they
just won't really allow a lot of housing
so I'm just curious whether you see a
tie in the way we allocate These funds
given that you are you know using
housing availability you know the
ability to expand housing Supply as a
reason so well I think that there's
several issues I the housing challenge
certainly is a town by Town situation
and I know the state is working very
hard on legislation that would enable
municipalities to have more access to
new dollars for things like water and
sewer expansion because when we have
small lot size and we have to build in
density of course that you can't put a
private well and a private septic tank
in I am not a housing expert and I don't
claim to be an economist there's
certainly other benefits and some were
touched upon in your last question about
how
well we allocate money to say a project
here in Concord they might be on the
list how many of us come to Concord to
to work to do our business to run state
government we eat in their restaurant so
of course we need that that clean access
to water and sewer and those upgrades
that haven't been done in many many
years I think housing is just one other
area that we have to consider and I know
that currently the state has an invest
New Hampshire program they are investing
dollars into these types of
studies and having municipalities
rethink how they can better maximize the
space that we do have so we can break
down some of the barriers you're talking
about in communities that say we just
can't but it's very hard to build a
fourplex on a half acre lot if there's
no infrastructure to tie into for
example thank you thank you
further questions from committee members
seeing none I have a question for you I
read some time ago that the majority of
the people in New Hampshire get their
water from private Wells
now you represent small towns as well as
cities the small towns I represent the
majority of people have private Wells
they're not really and they have two
acre lots by our zoning they're not
crazy about having someone come in and
cram more houses into smaller lots and
have them pay for a water system they
just as soon keep it the way it is and I
think your organization has to recognize
that
I'm not sure if there was a a question I
do know that some small towns do have a
small village district and anybody on
public water and sewer is taxed
separately for those services so if I'm
on a private well like myself my
downtown has access I'm in a town of
1600 my downtown has access to public
water and people can hook up to it
however there's going to be a point in
which the system is maximized because
it's a very small system but I myself am
on private water and sewer and you know
well water and septic and I don't pay a
separate tax bill
um for that service so the users pay the
fees associated with it and the way we
structure it in New Hampshire so my my
tax dollars are not going to that but I
am able when I use the park or when I go
to the town office or use the meeting
house or the space is available to me as
a member of the public I am able of
course to flush the toilet get drinking
water whatever the case may be
thank you any further questions from
committee members seeing none thank you
for your testimony thank you sir
next card I have is for Alex katrubus
and he's from acec New Hampshire he'll
tell us what that is
good morning thank you Mr chair
my name is Alex katrubis I'm here
representing ACAC New Hampshire which
stands for American Council of
engineering companies of New Hampshire
we're an association of about 70
engineering firms who have offices
throughout the state they employ about
1500 New Hampshire residents many of our
firms work with local municipalities on
Wastewater infrastructure projects that
as you've heard this morning are
critically important for our citizens
and our businesses in the state
New Hampshire engineering firms provide
comprehensive planning design
construction Administration operational
assistance Asset Management
to solve the complex challenges with
Wastewater
this program that we're talking about
this morning it was founded in 1990 it's
administered by Des as you've heard
since that time it's been a really
important funding tool for New Hampshire
cities and towns and without this
program a lot of the medium-sized
communities in the state probably
couldn't afford to invest in some of
these projects as you all know
municipalities basically only have the
property tax and maybe the registration
fee but the state has a lot a lot of
different Revenue sources that they can
pull from and send that money back to
the communities for worthy programs
so we believe that this is an important
program it'll improve not only
Wastewater systems but I agree I think
it could help with the housing
challenges that we face and general
Economic Development
I just wanted to representative McGuire
you asked the question about would it be
counted twice historically and I know Mr
chairman you know this this these bills
these Buko bucks bills if you will have
been retained by this committee and then
division one I believe is des uh you
know they will decide if 15 million is
the appropriate number or if it's some
other number and I presume that that's
what's going to happen with this bill
but obviously that's up to you folks and
in terms of pfas I'm not an engineer
there are filtration systems there's
charcoal systems there's remediation
systems I can put you in touch with
experts on this issue if you'd like Mr
chairman there's also a pfas remediation
fund that the legislature might remember
there was a bill last year uh 25 million
dollars to uh obviously the the
legislature passed uh standards for pfas
and um as part of that you appropriated
funds to help the communities meet those
standards so again I'm not an engineer
but I can I can certainly put you in
touch with experts on on pfas a lot of
our members are working with communities
like Litchfield and Merrimack who are on
The Cutting Edge of this uh this
important issue so thank you very much
appreciate it
thank you questions from committee
members
so I go back again
in your in your experience even though
you're not designing these plants how
much more complexity is there as we've
added these uh different rules for the
for the amount of pfas and so on that
can be in a system absolutely it's it's
a it's a big concern and obviously many
businesses were concerned about the cost
it does seem am I I don't want to speak
for Des but I do talk to them quite a
bit it seems like most of the
municipalities have been able to comply
I think the pfas fund has been helpful
so it doesn't seem like the standards
are as onerous as some of the business
groups uh had originally thought I
haven't heard a lot of pushback about it
the community seem to be in compliance
that's the information that I have but
certainly as the representative from the
Water Works Association it is costly for
these things and I believe that Senator
rashardi uh has a bill in the Senate to
I think it's what five million dollars
in that pfas remediation fund so I don't
know if that fund has been expended uh
or not but there was 25 million put in
last session and there's already a bill
to you know replenish it with five
million dollars I don't know what the
Genesis of that is at this point I don't
think it's on a public hearing yet but I
I to your point I think it's expensive
and it is complex and uh you know
programs like this this is not really
necessarily a pfas uh issue because this
is more waste water but on the drinking
water side certainly pfas is a very hot
topic right now
thank you representative Petrie for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh other
bad things in the water such as arsenic
right on how much more does that add to
the cost you think around the state I
mean it's a great question I I can get
you an answer to that uh I can talk to
my Wastewater engineering or excuse me
my drinking water engineering folks and
I'm sure that there's tables and um you
know in terms of how much the filtration
is for these various carcinogens but I
can't answer that at this point this
morning but I will follow up with you
representative
thank you and uh representative erf has
pointed out to me we're going to have a
pre-fiscal meeting here at the end of
all our hearings and uh
we have an item that will be on the
fiscal committee representative or if
you want to describe it
uh sure
so we're going to I think accept a
little over 1.3 million dollars
for Wastewater infrastructure from
federal government
um on Friday
representative
papavichi Mueller thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking the questions
oh if you could I apologize now
don't worry it's it's I'll try to answer
two questions very short one of which
I'm sure you can answer one of which I
would appreciate feedback later on first
question is what's the normal expected
life of one of these projects obviously
I expect that it's a long life asset but
I'd like to know how much and two could
you when you you know get back to your
office maybe email the committee with
some of the examples of medium-sized
communities that couldn't afford to run
the projects without a state
contribution thank you absolutely I mean
obviously it depends on the project but
I mean typically these are decades-long
systems you know uh
30 years maybe longer obviously they
need continuing maintenance but but I I
can again I'll give you a better answer
on both of those questions I will follow
up on all of these issues
thank you
representative Mooney for a quick
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
as one that represents a community that
has been
extraordinarily affected by pfas would
you agree that the reason why the cost
is so high and all these numbers are so
huge and these bills keep coming is
because pfas can't be contained it's
spreading to other communities other
towns I think we're just scratching the
surface in terms of the effects and the
mileage this problem can extend out to
do you agree I I do agree and I would I
would say that uh you know ACS is a
National Organization and New Hampshire
is really uh a leader on that issue we
were one of the first states to really
take Vermont was maybe excuse me a
little bit ahead but I think I think
you've done A legislature has done
really really great work on pfas
and I know you've been a big part of
that so I I def from the engineering
community it's been science based which
is important and we want to be partners
with you to uh and the communities to
get the uh the systems in in compliance
with these standards that you're that
you're setting with the Des and other
stakeholders
any further questions from committee
members on House Bill 311 seeing none I
will inform everyone that this will be
going to division one they will be
having further hearings on it and we'll
look into it further and bring their
recommendations back to the full
committee for action
I will now close the hearing on House
Bill 311.
we have about a three minute break if
anybody wants to just get up and stretch
and then we'll start right at 10 30.
and
I would like to
oh that's the next
it's just 311.
we had also the people that signed in
were the same ones that testified
Catherine heck and and I guess it's
oh Senate Senator Denise ricciardi
writes in in favor of it she signs the
list for Pro
thank you
it being 10 30.
I will open up a hearing on House Bill
384 and call upon the prime sponsor
representative emmerich
thank you Mr chair my name is Tracy
Emrick I represent Hampton Rockingham
District 29. I'm here this morning to
introduce a bill for a new parking
garage I think all of us have had the
opportunity at some point in our career
here to park at stores and there you'll
probably hear testimony from people more
knowledgeable about the condition of
stores at this point this bill is for 25
million dollars as a ceiling in order to
build a parking garage between
375 and 450 parking spaces the timeline
for construction from the time the
governor signs on signs off there's one
year for permitting engineering and one
year for construction so you've got two
years after it's signed so we're looking
at something in the future and that's
the extent of my knowledge but you've
got a lot of pink cards from people I
think that are much more knowledgeable
than I but I'll answer questions on my
limited knowledge
are there any questions for
representative Emrick
seeing none thank you for your testimony
we next have a card from the speaker at
areas represented speaker Sherman
Packard is recognized
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee
two years ago when I was elected into
the position
I thought I had a lot of things on my
plate this was not one of them
but the fact of the matter is it became
a reality and we have to address it
I want to just go over a little bit of
the history
of this
current garage over in store Street
the initial cost was seven million
dollars
maintenance stabilization sends
construction starting in 1983
has is 7.7 million dollars
just recently in 19
we appropriated 2 million 563 thousand
dollars and that was construction and
repairs were done in uh in 21.
the garage was built with a lifespan of
approximately 25 to 30 years
went out two years shy of 50 years
anybody that is parked over there has
noticed there's a double layer of
netting underneath the Upper Floor to
catch the concrete so it doesn't fall on
somebody or fall in the cars which has
happened
the bottom line is ladies and gentlemen
the garage at store street is falling
apart
we predict maybe a couple three years or
something and it would probably won't be
able to use it anymore
this is just reality
I did not want to spend 25 the 35
million dollars building a new parking
garage that money could have been spent
elsewhere but the fact of the matter is
if we don't build a new garage
many of you aren't going to have a place
to park
that that's just the bottom line uh
that's just reality
somebody break down
what we have right now
um we have 400 house members
24 senate members
126 full-time employees and 44 part-time
employees
spaces we have right now are 209 and
store Street
50 Street spaces uh 24th at Green Street
17 doj which will be gone uh 61 upper
level lob and 57 LOB
if we have a full session and every
member shows up for session we're about
40 to 50 spaces shy of even having a
place for them to park right now
so we're looking at a garage that will
accommodate
400 people this will put everybody
underneath the same roof it will uh
obviously we I I'm not a architect but I
would assume that you know we'll have
handicap spaces on the first floor we'll
have some charging stations probably on
the first floor all that has to be
worked out
that's just the Baseline of where we're
at
um
as representative Emrick said it's
probably going to take two two and a
half years to complete this project but
unless somebody has an alternative
where we can park people when store
street is not usable anymore
let me know but as to right now nobody's
been able to come up with a
alternative plan
um
as if anything
as the money we have to put into this
building every year this is what 200 and
someone years old it needs work that
garage is literally falling apart
and it needs to be replaced now's the
time to do it it's not going to get any
cheaper down the road
uh
I'll try and answer any questions that
don't have to go too deep into the
construction part of it we have plenty
of people here that can do that
thank you Mr Speaker any questions from
the committee members
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Speaker it wasn't this bill or a similar
one passed last year or some money
already allocated to this so money was
allocate yeah yes last year we passed
the bill I think it was nine and a half
million dollars that was the move the
Attorney General's office and refit the
building that we're moving them into and
that was also for the um you know the
preliminary destruction of the jail the
building over there
we didn't we didn't actually put money
into the budget last year last session
that had to do with the actual
construction of the building
so the previous parking garage we now
know is a design that lasted for 50
years couldn't it be torn down and
rebuilt with the same same plans and for
another 50 years
right now the city of Concord wants its
wants its space back
and if we tear down the parking garage
over there and we rebuild it over there
it's probably going to take the same
amount of time to two and a half three
years
where the hell you're going to park
everybody for three years
this solves the problem the AGS moving
down to uh you know the Financial
finance what is it Financial building
down the street about a mile down the
street they've already got uh working on
the uh all the inside construction that
they needed to do setting up the offices
uh and um you know they've already got
the lease signed for that building
so they're going to move in there right
I don't know probably within the next
two three months
any representative Murray thank you Mr
Speaker Mr chairman and welcome Mr
Speaker
um I remember speaking on this last year
the year before on the floor of the
house when we first started you know
this discussions were coming up it seems
to me I recall that the original
estimate was around 48 million in order
to do the entire project do you have any
sense or maybe someone here will know
where did we come up with the 25 million
because I do recall that it was quite a
bit more than that when we first or were
speaking well last last year
representative uh we were talking about
35 million dollars total
and that you know we we appropriated I
think it was 9.5 last year
last session and this is the 25 to
actually do the construction
see no further questions thank you Mr
Speaker
we'll next call on commissioner Charlie
Arley house from administrative services
good morning uh I'm Charlie arlinghaus
I'm the commissioner of administrative
services and uh joining me is um Ted
kupper who is our director of Public
Works and I will note that Ted is an
engineer
whereas I have no discernible Talent
um
but
um I uh so we were approached last year
the legislature wants to build a parking
garage on the site that currently
contains the Department of Justice
um and uh we've been working on that
process there was 9.35 Million
appropriated last year it includes money
for tearing down the Department of
Justice and the design and Engineering
work on the both the tear down of that
the teardown of storage Street and the
preliminary design and Engineering work
on planning for a garage I believe at
that time there were there was
discussion of 600 spaces 450 spaces 350
spaces and um
unfortunately our garage is the kind of
thing where where there's a little bit
of a plug-and-play aspect to it it's not
exactly fifty thousand dollars a space
but it's something like that and you can
figure that out
um we have uh gone back to the house and
and also some of that money is for
moving doj and retrofitting a building
which we now have a lease on
uh which is called Granite place and
used to House Lincoln Financial so
people describe it in 18 different ways
generally including either the word
Granite Financial or Lincoln but it's
that building that was once chub was
once Lincoln Financial so
um that's about a hundred thousand
square feet and the doj will occupy
about two-thirds of it
um so the cost of a cost of a garage is
um is probably as I say about
um about fifty thousand dollars of space
in theory a forty thousand a 450 space
garage would cost something like 22.5
million fewer spaces less than that the
exact price depends a lot on Market
design
Etc we have a uh we have a contract that
we're about to execute with um a company
called Scott and partners who's most
notable and they've done a lot of State
work but most notably for you that you
can see from here is they designed from
The Boiler House at the corner of green
and school I think is where that is
which people tend to appreciate because
it fits into the
historic district which is something
this garage would have to do wouldn't
just be a giant concrete structure but
would have to fit into the historic
district so you can build an attractive
parking garage
there is some evidence of that I've seen
pictures so we can do that we're here to
answer any questions you have about the
cost or about store Street or about the
garage itself or anything else related
to the project
and I can tell you what we've been doing
and Ted will be happy to answer
everything that's more technical
and uh
Public Works director would you spell
out your name please
uh it's Theodore and last name
k-u-p-p-e-r
thank you questions from the committee
representative hole
thank you Mr chairman
I know we've considered the Department
of Justice property the building is
worth approximately
um five million dollars or thereabouts
based on the assessed value that's on
the sheet although it is a
government-owned building and we don't
collect taxes what other
pieces of land within a reasonable
walking distance of of the State House
have been considered
I I don't know
um I know that over the years there's
been a lot of discussion about a lot of
pieces of property and
um none of which are owned by the state
currently and so I I know people looked
down State Street a bit and apparently
there's some some space behind some
buildings there all of those would have
acquisition costs
um I don't realistically know what else
is possible in in the sense of of State
ownership I mean could you theoretically
buy some you know building on Main
Street and tear down and do something
differently yes but I I don't know that
we've done any serious consideration of
any other site
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um right now the state of Storrs Street
makes it absolutely inaccessible to
those members who have Mobility
challenges and the majority of them are
parked in the street which this time of
year with the condition of the sidewalks
and the streets are I think are almost
even could be potentially worse
um
is the plan to have all of the
representatives who have disabilities
and Mobility challenges safely parked in
the new spot and will you be able to
accommodate everyone in there
I I think that exactly where where every
member is assigned would be would be a
decision for for legislative leadership
at that time I know that in designing
our garage we would build a garage that
had significant space for
um for people with disabilities
um
um both both handicap spaces and then a
number of spaces that are that
um even if you don't need a handicap
space that are more accessible just
because they're closer and the garage is
undercover Etc so the the mobility
issues is a significant aspect of the
design and I I would anticipate anyway
that everybody with a mobility issue I
don't know how many people that is today
it's not something we track although I'm
sure that other people do but I'm sure
they would be accommodated follow-up
thank you very much
um just sort of connected to that is
there a plan or an idea in place for the
safe
um movement of Parkers from the garage
to the yellow bee or to the state house
in terms of
um a tunnel crosswalks pedestrian
anything I think it's something that has
to be considered as part of a design I
mean my my sense is from preliminary
discussions with leadership that a
tunnel is probably out in large part
because of the water table and and if
you know much about the you know their
two tunnels now right the one of the
annex and the one of the lob and they're
often wetness issues there I think
people uh there's been an expression
that a tunnel is probably not ideal
but there have been various discussions
with the city about the state of Capitol
Street and what that would be and so
initially relatively easy access to the
lob itself but as part of any design
that access to the other buildings is
part of it but we're not anywhere down
the road on that thank you very much
hmm
further from the committee
represent Petrie thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question uh our
existing lob parking uh how many is that
hold and what's the lifespan
the the give me the garage behind the
lob correct oh my sense is it's about
you have about 120 people there now
um I don't actually know the lifespan of
it
I think it's okay though
it's certainly not like store Street
I don't think we have netting up
anywhere in the yellow B garage
any further questions for these
gentlemen
I would state that I am a co-sponsor
and I
have been here a while and have some
timeline worth mentioning
uh
this
store Street Garage is a clock there
dedicating it in 1976.
so in 1992 it was more than 25 years old
and perhaps needing replacement
at the time we voted to buy this
building that we presently consider the
The Edge the
Attorney General
for about two million dollars if I
remember right
and the idea was this is this is right
adjacent to us we can't let this go to
anybody else we need this for expansion
we're going to buy it now so it was
okayed and we bought that from the
Sherman bank that was moving out
subsequently
it's full of attorney general and
another bank
in 2005 I was again on a committee
to approve a new parking garage
and I was very dissatisfied with the
architect
who spent all this time with the city of
Concord and was just listening to what
they wanted
and even though we called it the
legislative parking garage I was the
only legislator there there was supposed
to be people from public works but they
didn't show up at the meetings
it was also available a small lot right
across the street from this building
where at one time I had a parking place
there were about 12 or 15 assigned
parking places in that lot
and part of the plan we looked at in
2005 would have cleared that lot so we
could take the people that were parking
here and move them up over the people
who were parking across the street to
move them over there as we tore down the
building it also came through again
legislative parking garage but the
Attorney General was asking for 20
percent more space
So the plan that came out they were
going to put it right up to the sidewalk
so they could make more room for the
Attorney General they were going to put
in the parking garage but because they
were going to put it right up against
the sidewalk they were going to close
this Street behind us
and I thought that's not a good idea how
do we get to this parking behind the lob
or we'll build a ramp off this other
Street
what are we gonna what's that gonna cost
well about three spaces in that lot at
the time we were thirty three thousand
dollars a piece for each space and of
course it had to look fancy because that
was what Concord wanted
which I thought was who's leading this
parade and then
the speaker may remember we
we did
pass something that came to Public Works
and uh the plan because of the way they
did it and I mean looking at the
legislature as the last person to
have any input even though it was
considered the legislative parking
garage
all these other people had input so it
failed it would have meant and the
subsequent time that a lot that we were
going to clear because there was a
building there for sale
has been sold and a brand new building
is moored up within the last few years
so lots of things have happened as we
delay this and
I remember at one point when we had to
design it we also had to design it for
the bank and have 15 parking places for
them
now
I don't believe there's a bank there
anymore so that that's gone away so it
would just be pretty much a parking
garage there may be offices in it for
the people in security one of the things
I suggested at the time was to build a
walkway
like from the second or third floor
coming into this building so that you
would need only one elevator the ones we
have here and they handicapped people
could go across that walkway
and into access the elevators in this
building
none of that has has happened but anyway
I just thought I'd share that because I
have been involved with this for some
years and
you can see if they decided in 92 to
replace the parking garage why are we
still talking about it in 2023 and when
are we going to get going so thank you
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
on my experience and what what I've seen
thank you
I would assure you Mr chairman that we
know for whom we work
you do but the city of Concord thinks
they own it
and
our chief of chief of operations Terry
puff is here uh if you want to add
anything you may have
memories that I thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Terry Poff I'm the Chief
Operating Officer for the general court
for you folks as well as the senate in
one of the jobs outlined in my position
is long-range planning facility
maintenance facility care among
Administration for all joint employees
so as a matter of History just briefly
the store Street Garage as the speaker
mentioned was was built for seven
million dollars in 1975 the same time
that the additions were put onto this
building and this became a legislative
office building so the LLB parking
garage is approximately the same age
and that is in need of repair and is
going to get repairs done this I believe
this summer or it's in the pipeline for
repairs because there are things that
are falling on cars in the lob parking
garage as well because they're just that
old this one was designed with a longer
life span than the steel I-beam parking
garage that was built down there and and
we have an air lease with the city of
Concord for 99 years and we've exhausted
half of that pretty much so that's a
little bit of the history of that garage
and we as the speaker mentioned we put
in 7.7 million since 1983 just in
stabilization dollars to make sure that
we can get an extended life out of a
25-year building into what we are
existing with right now
but it
the the pandemic did one good thing for
us and that was reduced the use of that
facility so with the reduction of the
use of that facility for that length of
time that extended the lifespan for when
you folks came back into this building
so just be cognizant of that they
reduced the the use and extended the
life so that we could get this garage
built and as you said Mr chairman that
piece of property in 1993 I was a public
works member at the time myself in the
house it was purchased and authorized
through facilities the facilities
Committee of the general court and it
was purchased with collaboration with
the city of Concord for a parking garage
to be put there eventually because of
the proximity to this building
so it's it's overdue it's time it's here
it's not a want it's a knee it's a
necessity as the speaker explained and I
think that's just where we are the as
the folks from Das and DPW mentioned uh
the costs are about fifty thousand
dollars a space give or take and it
depends on the design of what we find on
that site we've done several uh to
answer
um I believe representative Maguire's
questions there has been other locations
looked at as you mentioned Mr chairman
there's been several around this the
State House complex looked at
they would have required an acquisition
uh
to acquire property and cost more money
and they just weren't available it just
wasn't doable at the time we actually
had some preliminary designs on one on
the corner that would have taken the
pharmacy building and made it like an L
there and it would have Incorporated
representative Sweeney's question would
have been Incorporated some office space
for the general court at that point as
well and it was a preliminary thought of
putting some office space in at the doj
site in conjunction with the parking
garage but that sense because of cost
constraints has gone asunder too
we are at capacity in these two
buildings as you all well know and so we
are looking at uh innovative ways to
house staff and membership as you know
your committees are getting high much
more attendance in the Committees from
the general public and others and so
larger rooms are sometimes needed you're
getting moved to the the house chamber
at times so there were thoughts at some
point of making larger rooms that hold a
higher capacity of people so that you
could have hearings and the Senate could
have hearings that have has a higher
capacity for audience attendance
but we're not there what we are doing is
is acting and hopefully you folks will
look upon this favorably and act uh to
fill a need not a want this is a
necessity
and with that I'll gladly answer any
questions you may have
all right you have 35 more minutes to
speak if you wish
questions from the members
representative papovich thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
questions would you be able to provide
us with a you know proforma analysis of
the costs of each trying to extend the
life of the you know stores garage which
is currently on life support versus you
know obviously we understand what the
costs are for replacing it but just to
evaluate you know what may happen in
both scenario in terms of dollars we'd
have to spend the cost of extending it
is pretty much Demolition and rebuilding
if you can if you want to rebuild but in
conjunction with the city of concord's
Master Plan their master plan doesn't
include that garage being there to be
honest with you and there they have a
master plan that's redoing that whole
store Street section that goes clear to
Horseshoe Pond so that's going to be
like the Gateway into Concord so we
collaborate in the city of Concord are
our partners really in this because we
are here they're our neighbors we work
with them so the extension of life is is
not really feasible thank you for that
property
representative McGuire and then
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I've heard various numbers of the
size of the garage we're targeting here
at 450 600 other numbers what what
actually is it
what is the actual number of the spaces
the number of spaces the need for the
space for the 25 million dollars and the
25 million dollars can be approximately
uh what was the 450 for 22. 400 for 22
million dollars
is what the the need the need is 400
minimum the desire would be to have some
more so we could accommodate our
partners over at the Das and the Annex
Building because they have a genuine
need for parking too and you have to
understand that folks that work down
down here and they're they're doing
Public Service in this not only on our
Branch but in the other branches parking
is a genuine concern and it it's a
genuine problem for retention of
employees quite frankly and even initial
hiring so when you look at those parking
it's not just to park the car it's to
retain and recruit employees
to make the process work here and also
to for government in general and even
private practice and Private Industry
follow it follow-up yeah along those
lines
um
how many employees of the state work in
this Capital Area I mean there's also
the State Library other places and where
do they Park we have different lots and
different surface parking around and
then we have accommodations
within the different divisions and I
can't speak for the executive branch
exclusively only our Branch but we have
surface parking behind the library that
we have some of our legislative
employees housed in we have surface
parking on green and School Street
behind the boiler plant we actually
relinquished spaces in that lot for
several things four spaces for Ev
vehicles to have EV charges were the
first places to do that we're kind of
leading the way in that because some of
our members in the general court
actually had some EVs and general public
can use that as well we relinquish
spaces to actually create and put the
Boiler House there we even had some
preliminary designs to put the boiler
the boilers to feed this area after
Concord steam went down in the basement
of a design of the garage on the doj
site so we have doj site spaces for doj
employees and executive Branch employees
as well as legislative employees and
members so we're
patchworked around for folks to to park
and then we also have parking cards that
we provide as a service for parking on
city streets as well and then we have an
agreement with the city to use surface
parking for handicapped folks on Park
Street on North State and um and Capitol
street so we're
we're sprawled all over the place and
and is when you have some members able
to park here and members of the House in
the Senate able to park here but the
Senate pretty much is in this contained
in this area because there's so few of
them but the house members really you
have half of your body part a distance
away and with that average age of our
membership these days about 63 and a
half and that's because we have some 18
and 20 year olds quite frankly so and we
be so we uh you know that's not exactly
an ideal situation for anybody because
you have two classes as a former speaker
Jasper and current commissioner has said
before it's two classes of legislators
the ones that park close to the Capitol
complex and the others that are footing
it from uh from a distance and quite
honestly it's it's uh it storms like
this it's not it's dangerous for folks
to be quite honest and they're serving
for
um as basically volunteers here so we
want to do what's safe for them
um one more I I didn't quite hear a
number in there is is uh 400 is the uh
is the minimum goal no no about how many
um employees we currently have how many
employees we currently have we have 126
full-time employees and about 44
part-time employees so is that 160
spaces or
that are scattered around scattered
around as well as as well as the 424
members gotcha thank you
I can remember when everybody had a
handful of quarters and they had to run
out every couple hours and put them in
the parking meters and now they've got
the kiosk but it's the same deal you got
to keep running out and getting another
one representative Heath real quick
thank you Mr chair
um is there a cost
um to the um to the House and Senate
um in the body for using all these
spaces from Concord I I would think that
um just knowing that everybody has a
tech space and parking is one of those
revenues that people count on is there
an agreement with with this body and the
City of Concord for payment of some sort
as I said the general court is a good
neighbor and the Concord city of Concord
is a good neighbor with us as well so we
have an agreement and they've authorized
us a certain number of spaces on the
streets and as well as what Concord does
they have an ordinance that allows
handicapped folks to park uh with no
cost either so if they have a hand a
hand a hang tag they can park there as
well at any City space but we have a
particular agreement and a special
agreement with the city of Concord for
those spaces around the capital complex
that we consume on a regular basis and
we are cognitive of the fact cognitive
of the fact uh Revenue issues so we on
mask you know how we have the the bags
and the cones we remove those as soon as
we can when we know the need's not there
so we watched that constantly we're
sensitive to the fact that it's a
revenue stream for the city and that
they're generous to give us those things
so we we appreciate it and we appreciate
our neighbors to the to just to the west
of us all right thank you
representative Murray for a question
thank you Mr Speaker I am not at all
competent in construction and all that
but I'm curious when you're trying to
figure out the number of spaces that
this could have going from smaller to
the larger is there any sense of looking
at economy of scale of having you know
if you have the more spaces would that
reduce the 5 50k that you're proposing
per space or is that the range of that
still so small that it wouldn't have any
impact on the cost per space no they
actually have brought that up when we
had our
pre-architectural meetings with the
architect and stuff they said there is a
sweet spot um for the decks because each
deck can carry so many and it depends on
how much you consume of that site so
there are architectural parameters that
create the sweet spot for the cost and
they're going to look into those but
quite honestly when you as the as the
commissioner mentioned I believe or or
the director
this is a wet spot it's a they don't
call it Spring Street by chance it's for
a reason so nine on a drought year when
we had some drilling done over there in
the past it's been they went down nine
feet in a drought season in August and
they hit water almost Artesian type
water at 9.8 feet so it's pretty wet
around here and so it makes for a poor
construction site but a great site
proximity was
representative leishman for a question
thanks Mr chairman and thanks for taking
my question it's kind of a follow-up to
representative Heath the number of
spaces that we have around the lob in a
state house that are occupied are given
to us if you will by the city will any
of those spaces be returned back if the
parking garage is built we anticipate
that yes a lot of them will be returned
back we'll keep a minimum amount around
um the base of the of the capital itself
but most of the other parking will all
be accommodated within the new structure
and the new structure will have uh it's
going to be a requirement it is in
design really for Ev spaces for handicap
spaces and several other minimum
requirements
you know modern day garages or modern
day garages that they've have control
points uh camera systems the whole bit
because security is becoming and always
has been a Paramount but when you build
something new you need this secure
facility thank you thank you Mr chairman
further questions from committee members
your title
I'm not sure I gave you the correct time
it's Chief Operating Officer for the
general court
thank you
is there anyone else that would like to
say anything about this proposal on
House Bill 384. Mr three wait a minute I
got the number wrong
384 yes that's it
all right
representative McGuire you have a
question no uh we need to
uh so thank you Mr chairman and just
along the lines of of your own little
talk here I wanted to just
and give my perspective um I heard you
say that when you were studying this
problem in the past you were looking at
parking garages that cost thirty three
thousand dollars a space
what we're looking at today 35 million
dollars for 450 spaces or 400 spaces or
whatever that's more like seventy five
thousand dollars a space
and I just have a mental disconnect
because you know I paid under thirteen
thousand dollars for my car
a few years ago you know so so you know
parking that car in a 75 000 space just
seems crazy that's my problem I heard
fifty five thousand
of roughly 50.
for the actual construction the entire
project right yeah yeah yeah and that's
you know and that's per so that's about
50 000 per space
and of course there's been a lot of
inflation since 2005. even more in the
last year yeah so everything is going to
be more expensive and then we're also
going to hear about problems getting the
building materials so
yeah the sooner we get to it you can see
how much it's cost when I think my
recollection the speaker may have
remembered 92. I think we bought this
building for 2 million maybe two point
something million but it
I don't know if anybody knows exactly
question over here
representative Edwards for a question uh
yes sir thank you Mr chair I I I just
need a mental refresh I I thought we did
something in hb2 that arranged for this
garage to be built and at least
partially funded and and and to
representative McGuire's point I hope
the parking spot lasts longer than your
car uh
yes I think we did put money in hb2 but
I don't think it anything is is moved
forward
so my point there is I'm a little
confused why why we keep coming back to
this issue I thought it was a dead
letter
if I may Mr chairman the money we put in
last session representative Edwards was
for the move for the Department of
Justice
to move over to the building that
they're currently going built building
out the space for them to move into
it also had money in there for the
preliminary tear down of the doj
and doing the architectural work for the
garage itself that was all combined into
I think was 9.5 million
that had nothing to do with the actual
construction of the garage itself
we didn't have
good enough numbers last year on the
actual construction so we didn't ask for
any money and that's why we're coming
back this year to ask for the money for
the actual construction of the garage
uh thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Speaker
if anything further
I have
on the blue sheet
representative Tim Harrigan is is signed
up in favor representative commissioner
arlinghaus we've already heard from him
also online uh House Bill 384 support or
oppose
Daniel Richardson from Nashua opposed
Patricia Anastasia from Londonderry
opposed
okay do we have anything else yeah
yeah this is
testimony from online and from HB 311.
okay HB 311 this was online
some of it is is letters that will be in
the folder for you to read
here's the group of people that have
signed online Brian Getz from Portsmouth
supports Jared mariaro lmac chair for
Meredith supports
Jason Gagnon from Conway supports Jason
Randall from Plymouth support
champuglio from Milford support
Michael L Tremblay
Penacook support
Sheila Connolly from holderness support
Vanessa Sheehan I believe she's a rep
Milford support
Daniel Richardson Nashua opposed
Catherine heck that was nhma supports
representative Nancy Murphy from
Merrimack support Susan Richmond from
Durham support William hounsel North
Conway support and then there's a group
of letters
in digging through some
old material I found some architectural
rendering that I will add to their
pictures of this fancy building that
would have been put over here in the
elimination of traffic on this street
behind us so it might be worthy of a
look for
an expensive project that was even
turned down in 2005.
Mr Speaker anything further
if if I just answer representative
zoleski's question on the handicapped
every year
that those of us that have done parking
it's been an absolute nightmare because
every year we have more and more people
that need handicapped parking spaces
and we have to leave about five or six
open for those that might need a
temporary one whether it be an accident
or something of that nature so we always
have five or six left open which we've
already filled three of them I think
this year
you know for people that have had
handicapped things that might only last
for three or four months uh it's a
nightmare uh it's not going to get any
better
and um
unfortunately sometimes people come to
us and we don't have any place to put
them so so building this will eliminate
that particular problem uh but um at the
current
rate we're doing things right now
future speakers are going to have one
heck of a time if they don't have some
place to put the members and the staff
thank you for that having needed one of
those spaces after having surgery my
first term I understand the challenges
with it and I'm glad to know that
that'll be addressed and our members
will be have a safe place
and this bill will now go to division
one for further review
they have and representative leishman
has scheduled it for next Tuesday
the 31st
after it'll be the
fifth bill
that day at 1 30 House Bill 384 division
one will be hearing further so
if there's nothing further
I will close the hearing for now on
House Bill
384 and you have about a 10 minute break
before we start our 11 30 hearing
I didn't want to say anything
okay in one minute we'll open a hearing
good morning
I will open the hearing on House Bill
call on one of the sponsors
representative Stapleton
good morning and thank you Mr chair and
the members of the committee for
enabling me to speak as a co-sponsor on
this bill
I am for the record
Walter Stapleton Sullivan County
district 6 Claremont and Croydon
I am not
intimately familiar with the site
and many of the aspects of this so I'm
going to talk in a general sense
about this project and this bill
historically
Railroad and utility rights away are
very expensive
and a great deal of effort to Pure
procure
and that was you know many years ago
decades hundreds of years ago when it
was easier now it's even more difficult
and when we have these assets
of rail utility rights of way even if
they're
discontinued from their original use as
in rail trails
these are still very viable important
assets
I happen to be a bicycler and a hiker
and I've used with great satisfaction
and fun many of the rail trails in this
state and in other locations
so one of the quality aspects of a
recreational use of rail trails
is an uninterrupted and non-conflicting
aspect with other traffic and and usages
so if when you truncate them
you have dead spots
shoe flies run arounds this is a
detraction in the quality of the trail
and oftentimes may represent a
compromise of safety to the trail users
as well as the other traffic modes and
intersections
and if there are other
um obstacles like Cliffs mountains
Springs Brooks
whatever that represent compromise of
safety that's a further
concern in that regard
but beyond the use of the rail trail for
recreational and personal use
these are really important and viable
assets
to maintain the Integrity of Rights of
way
for utility
pipe Gas Electric
um
the
various components of
cables that might be able to use and
railroads have traditionally been
extending rights of wave to both power
overhead and
infrared cables
for communication
purposes and this technology increases
the need for these things very integral
rights of way are important for
that expanded use
so in this case
enabling this box tunnel to be built
continues the Integrity of the
right-of-way for all of those purposes
and I would even place the importance of
those purposes on utility and
right-of-way usage for important
technological
uses even as important or even above
those of recreational
so I stand in support of 506 and
encourage the committee to pass on it
and to maintain the Integrity of this
important right-of-way asset
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee representative
Griffin
yes can you um thank you Mr Chad
thank you
could you tell the committee uh what the
purpose is of the sentence that begins
on line three
that deals with a Class A misdemeanor
thank you for the question I just wanted
to review what was said in there I did
not write the legislation however
um
projects of a very important nature and
I believe that this isn't a category of
that needs to have some protection
against protesters or actors who might
interrupt the construction and delay and
therefore cost increase the cost of of
this project
further questions from the committee
members representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair I I have four points if if
if you'd let me make them I'll come to
you each time but
um on line two uh the uh project is
described as a rail trail box tunnel
option on Interstate 93 exit 4A uh that
I I perceived that to be too generic to
really offer a lot of use to us I I I
would what do you think about having
that made more precise so we know what
the intent is it's my understanding that
there's a potentially multiple routes
that could be selected and so I'd like
to know what route is anticipated to use
State funding we may have someone from
the dot that will be able to answer that
question I'll suspend I can go to point
two if I may
um on line four
the use of the word penalty is used at
the end of that sentence and it says the
penalty in this section shall include
these people and I don't know who
they're supposed to punish but I suspect
there's a typo there
the the penalty in this section shall
include the project manager lead project
engineer and the commissioner of the dot
so so I think I think there's something
wrong with that sense
do you see it and how would that get
fixed yes thank you for the question
thank you for pointing out those details
um I would preface my remarks by saying
I wish I had had more opportunity and
time to review and then make some
recommendations on these sort of items
uh yeah that's unclear and needs
clarification the penalty it seems like
there's missing words in there or a
distracted thought thank you so much
on the other question relative to the
Interstate 93 exit 4A I agree that there
should be some further references to
local roads adjacent contingent to
relative to what the um
a shoe fly or the runaround would be as
an alternative and if there are any
other geographical conditions there like
Brooks streams water courses whatever
that that are a contingent or adjacent
to these particular project area
thank you sir so so I have two more
um I I following along with what
representative Griffin I think opened
the door on is uh you know I would be
opposed to adding to the criminal code
in this funding bill I I don't I don't
believe that's appropriate I believe
that the
um the the intent to allow construction
to go forward is a good one do you do
you think that there's already uh
criminal code that would deliver the
protection this project is wanting
afforded to it
thank you again for that question yes I
agree that we have ample code in law and
Alternatives in law to remedy or to
discourage Interruption of this or any
other project
and then my final
thank you for your forbearance sir
um
you know given that given that this is
trying to hire three new people and that
the state is on the hooks for some of
the money at least it it just strikes me
that we may want to have a completion
date or a Sunset date so that it's clear
when the state is no longer entangled in
this execution of this project what do
you think about potential Sunset data or
project completion date
I have not been able to
take a look at prospective project
parameters
so you know the length of construction
is
could be determined by the extent of the
project
and I couldn't even give a guesstimate
as to when a sunset or termination date
might be appropriate
um and and therefore maybe that is a
further for Amendment
um with regard to looking at the project
parameters and details and then coming
up with such a Sunset date yeah I and I
am looking at the sponsor list I
consider you all friends and smart
people and these comments were intended
to be helpful
I'm sorry again please
um I I was attempting to be helpful
because I as I look at the sponsor list
I I know all of you I respect all of you
I'm I'm sure you're trying to do the
right thing I just I'm just not sure
this is the right it's it's not ready I
don't think I understand uh I I signed
on to this conceptually as I expressed
in my introduction
um and I'm sorry that I'm bereft of some
of the important details to help this
committee further at this point
any further questions from committee
members
representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman and thank you I
can understand your passion for wanting
to have this project and get it done
timely but I'm having difficulty getting
over lines three through four is it your
intention to create an entirely new
misdemeanor aimed at three specific
individuals and if so is there any
precedent for that
yeah that's that's a little bit out and
outer limits
and again I
I did not have the time or take the time
to look at this closer and I'm sorry for
that
um
having heretofore been able to
evaluate that I would have made some
constructive recommendations
and the penalty aspect doesn't doesn't
seem to fit because we have code and law
already for answering any problems with
this regard
any further questions from committee
members
seeing none thank you representative
Stapleton for your testimony thank you
I will next call on representative Peter
stamness who's from the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation
you have other people you want to
testify as well
push that make if it's red it's ready no
sir okay I'll be the only one testifying
Mr chair
um members of the committee my name is
Peter stamness the director of project
development for the dot
um
been with the dot
um 36 years and prior to this position
I spent 10 years as a project manager
for I-93 sailing to Manchester which
this um construction project exit 4A
um
is a new exit on I-93 so I'm
pretty familiar with the with the
history of the project and um have been
involved in in a significant number of
of meetings on the project and the
details of this so
um
and uh dot opposes this bill
um I'll give you a little bit of
information on the proposed layout and
there were some questions about the
differences between the two layouts um
the bill mentions a tunnel option
the proposed option the preferred option
by the dot and
um townedary who supports it
um
is a
is a a less direct route than the tunnel
option it's we call it the scenic route
and it was developed as a refinement and
a cost-saving alternative to the
original design which was
um the tunnel option
the uh this this proposal provides a
safe grade separated Crossing that is
ADA Compliant
it improves and I mean grade separated
meaning the trail goes under the road
under Folsom Road similar to the tunnel
option so there is no
um
conflict between Trail users and
vehicles on Folsom road so it goes under
Folsom Road utilizing a a Bridge
Crossing so this is a there's a bridge
that crosses the river
um Shields Brook and the uh this this
alternative
um will take the trail under that bridge
adjacent to the river and connect it to
the rail trail on both ends the North
and South End
the proposed layout improves access and
continuity to the sidewalks on Folsom
Road this isn't just a rail trail it
also
connects to the sidewalks on the north
and south side of Folsom Road and
there'll be connectivity to those
sidewalks
um which will be more direct for this
proposed alternative the scenic route as
opposed to the tunnel row
um this alternative doesn't require a
second structure so that's identified as
a cost savings and that was one of the
main driving elements of
um us
um
utilizing or preferring this this option
and eliminates a structure from a
maintenance role so this will um this
will be owned and maintained by the town
of Derry and one more structure that
that doesn't need to be maintained
um it received public input at multiple
meetings
and it's supported by the Derry Town
Council
and um it's really a sensible balance of
all stakeholder interest so
um in my experience there have been very
few projects who that have received 100
support
um you know we try to balance all of
um
all of the concerns and it's and it's a
difficult job to do that
and we feel that this this solution does
that
um and and
what this bill will do
[Music]
um
um if it requires a change in design so
right now we are advancing the scenic
route uh the one structure alternative
and if we advance or change uh course
and go with the tunnel option which is
suggested in the bill
it will cause additional delays to the
construction schedule
and so that's a reason for the
opposition and I'll also note that I'm
not one of the people who are mentioned
in in the bill but I know that the other
three who are and um you know the threat
of incarceration certainly caught my eye
any questions from committee members
representative heward and representative
McGuire
thank you
from Reading from reading this bill I I
take it it's been decided that what is
going to be built uh
is a rail trail box tunnel and not
nothing else no no sir no
that's what the bill would would prefer
us to construct
well
if you
name me one additional
choice that you have as far as this
project
other than a rail a rail trail box
tunnel what else could you do
um the preferred alternative
takes the rail trail
and it
um passes it through and under a a
proposed Bridge
um that right now there's a probably a
five foot diameter
um Culvert that that takes five or six
foot diameter Culvert that takes Shields
Brook
um under Folsom Road we're putting a 90
foot long bridge there and the rail
trail will go under that bridge and
connect to the south end of the rail
trail and the North End of the rail
trail on the opposite side of Folsom
Road
a follow-up follow-up
um
so
even it would go underneath the bridge
but it wouldn't be called there wouldn't
be a box tunnel there right no okay we'd
utilize the exist the proposed structure
that's going to be used to carry
Vehicles over
um shieldsburg
okay so the so the
um
penalties
imposed is for
impeding a a box Tunnel construction so
if you've did something else this
wouldn't apply right
uh that I the way I read it is if we
don't do a box Culvert then
um then there's penalties
that's the way I read it but I could be
wrong
okay one could even read it to say that
any state representative that impedes
we have a penalty thank you Mr chairman
especially that's up to the judge but I
think
that in a wider sense of reading it any
person
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I had a hard time
following your your testimony because
I'm not familiar with this exit Etc do
you already have or maybe you could
create a side-by-side document that that
says the rail trail box tunnel option
versus the scenic route option and
different features of each or maybe
drawing of each or you know cost of each
and that sort of thing a kind of a side
by side
um we we've got lots of uh documentation
on the various Alternatives and I I
could uh I could provide that to you
thank you
representative tolerski for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um so if I understand this correctly
this project is already in process with
the Department of Transportation with
the approval of the town of Derry
everyone's on board and uh the funds are
there ready to go as far as I can tell
what the fiscal note scheduled for this
summer
knowing I don't want you to try to
project what was in the minds of the
people who drafted this bill but in your
interactions with the development of
this project with the town of Derry can
you Enlighten us a little bit on what
the opposition might be to the existing
project that's already been approved and
why they would prefer this
um
I think they wanted to the uh the
advocates for the tunnel option want the
direct route the straight shot
um
through the box Culvert under the road
um the
um
alternative that is being proposed is
around a thousand feet longer from a
trail standpoint because
there's grades that need to be
um
accounted for and so there's some
curvature to the trail and
um so the the
point A to point B is about a thousand
feet longer
in in the state's proposal than the
trail Advocates
proposal and
um
I believe and and glean this from
multiple conversations and meetings that
they prefer the the direct route because
they feel that it's more of a it could
be used as a commuting route and that
they feel
um
that that a direct route is is safer
follow-up
follow-up would I be correct though and
what I stated also that this project is
planned approved budgeted for and on
track to happen anyway this summer
um it's already under construction so
there's three there's three uh contracts
um included in this Corridor project one
is already under construction
this element uh this this this portion
of the of the corridor
um is under design it has been on hold
while we navigate the challenges around
[Music]
you know the the the the the the the
approach and the in the location of this
rail trail so we put our pencils down
and we waited until we got the support
that we needed and we had additional
meetings to gather input
um
we do we
we have one more
um element from a from a cultural
resource standpoint that we need to
finalize
um and we've we've got basic agreement
for from all the stakeholders resources
we just need to get a final approval
from the Federal Highway
um on on the The Adjustment that we made
through the design
and
um follow-up following up on this you
know the delays um that we've that we
have had
um right now we uh plan to move into
construction on the second phase in 2024
and the third phase of the Year
following that 2025 with a full
completion date of 2028 for the corridor
that's where our timetable is right now
thank you very much
representative papovichi Muller for a
question thank you Mr chair actually I
have a few but I will ask for permission
every time
thank you for taking the questions
um let me preface this by saying that
I'm from Windham which is a community
that's near you know the location and uh
quite a few of our residents do use or
plan to use that part of the rail trail
I should also say that I'm not a real
Trail user myself but you know I do hear
a lot about it from the people in my
community could you clarify to start
with how much of the change between you
know the original plan which was the
tunnel to the current one which you know
we can call it the current one was
driven by cost and how much by safety
I've heard news reports I've seen news
reports that oh it's really about safety
that it's really about cost I would
appreciate a understanding of how much
each of those was a part of the decision
[Music]
um
it was mostly
um about the cost savings we were
looking for ways to bring the cost of
the project down and given the times
that we're in it you know their their
escalation going on that continues to
move
um but we
um have
um engineered a safe solution it's ADA
Compliant
um
and
some would suggest and and I'm I'm I I'm
a Believer in this I've also used the
rail Trails
um with my family
um and I when we're when you're walking
on the rail trails and it and you're
shared with with bikers um you need to
pay attention to where you're walking
and if someone Strays you know you it
you know because the bikers they go and
and they're welcome to do that
um you know we've introduced some some
curvature to the trail that will slow
you know bring the the you know the
speeds closer together with the
different users
um and we have grades that are
appropriate for
um Ada to make them ADA Compliant and
we've widened the trail in areas where
there is curvature to improve safety and
so
um I I believe I believe that we've got
a safe solution and um it's at a cost
savings
um to State of New Hampshire thank you
may I so the um
I've heard a lot from a lot of residents
about how this makes the rail trail
harder to use and you know just less
enjoyable and
you know this is a permanent project
right it's not like we are going to
redesign this so we are talking about a
one-time expense that needs to be
carefully considered against usability
concerns that will extend for many
decades going forward have you have has
the department considered that you know
drop in usability for the trail is part
of the balancing the costs versus the
return you know
again I think I think
it's pretty subjective
um some might think that the the more
curvilinear Trail the scenic route
taking it down by the uh
Shields Brook
um wide open Airy Crossing is going to
be more enjoyable than a straight shot
Trail through a long
tight box Culvert
um
you know it that we we ran into
um as we advance the design we found
that uh there was a shallow ledge and
groundwater issues that complicate the
overall design and construction and also
the long-term uh maintenance
responsibilities for the structure it's
going to need to be lit it's the the
lighting in the tunnel is going to need
to be maintained
um there are many people who would
choose not to go through a tunnel like
that because they feel it's unsafe so
it's it's you know it's dependent on on
your perspective I think it's very
subjective
um and how you feel about that
particular Crossing
one more follow-up
thank you you stated earlier that you
have basic agreement from all the
stakeholders does that include the local
rail trail alliances are they considered
still hurt stakeholders and have they
agreed to the new design
um early on when
um this this alternative was conceived
we did get
a letter of support
from the rail trail group
and we took that at at face value they
do not support the option that um
that we are proposing
thank you and one question for you Mr
chair if I could
um and for the record that rail trail
support letter that you received was
rescinded uh you know later so now as
you just said the rail trailers do not
support the current the proposed
solution
is that that's good right so because I
do consider the rail trails and you know
the local people who are very involved
in this to be significant stakeholders
and
I am shocked that they are not here to
testify and the only explanation I can
think of is that they did not realize
this bill was on the schedule it's very
hard for normal people to keep track of
the house schedule is there any way to
have a second hearing on this bill just
to make sure that all those people that
showed up at every meeting related to
this for the local meetings have an
opportunity to testify
you should go to division two and they
will have another hearing and that will
be an opportunity and we did have
oh is it too
it's on it's on your schedule all right
I'll go to division one
thank you
and
it is
not because it is dealing with DOT which
is the
um oversight by division two
so
oh rails this is Department of Natural
Resources which handles the rail Trails
which goes to division one we've run
into these things before so
between the two of you obviously it's
it's gone to division one because it is
a rail trail bill
and
they would welcome dot to come into the
hearing and anybody else that wants to
go hopefully we will see all these
sketches and so on and there's another
curious aspect here that no one has
brought up yet
savings from the elimination of the
shared use Crossing
of 375 thousand I wonder how that that
is a savings
the 375 I'm that yeah it has it has in
the bill
the department of state's the department
States the tunnel is estimated to cost
one million one hundred and twenty five
thousand to build and savings from the
elimination of the shared use Crossing
375 000 results in a net construction
fiscal impact of approximately 750
000.
which is no one has commented on that I
thought I'd bring it up yeah 750 000
savings
no with 375 000 savings by eliminating
a shared use Crossing what is that
if I may
representative erf wants to comment I I
think what they're saying is what you're
doing is going to cost some money and by
applying that money to the 750 they get
up to their total
what the intent of the statement is to
um is to say that by eliminating
um and not constructing the second
structure there's a cost savings to the
project of seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
there is some additional costs that are
associated with
um the uh preferred alternative the
scenic route that goes under the uh the
uh the bridge the the roadway bridge
that cuts into uh the cost savings so
the the Box Culvert would be 1.125
million and there's some additional
costs for the one structure that would
be included with the project of 375 and
the net difference is the 750.
maybe that could be worded a little
differently but there are there was some
additional work that was necessary to
the shields Brook Bridge Crossing to
accommodate the rail trail passing under
the bridge
retaining wall work and and and such so
thank you
further questions from committee members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and you and okay representative McGuire
has a question thank you just since you
brought this up so the so the fiscal
note says there's an additional 112 Five
that's going to be needed for design so
am I is am I reading this right that the
750 and the bill is inadequate to do
this full job
you're reading it correctly
and one may I follow up and is it
anticipated that this money would come
from the highway fund or because the
bill doesn't seem to specify yeah I'm
not I'm not sure where the money's going
to come from I see thank you
any further questions
remember representative Hewitt
now that I'm reading the methodology
it says that the bill makes a 750 000
general fund appropriation for thistle
yet 2024 to be used for cost related to
the rail trail box Tunnel construction
project
all right here we go
um
the
if you're not building the rail trail
box tunnel
um
then I want to know what the 750 000
pertains to in other words if you're if
if you've uh
if you've had
uh funds if you had funds uh
appropriated before this or is it 750
000 the first shot
the
in the current proposal
the tunnel the Box Culvert is not
included okay
The Advocates
would like it included
and and if we include it
it'll cause it'll be a capital cost of
approximately 750 000 dollars plus
there'll be another 100 and something
and change for uh design because we have
to go back and we have to negotiate with
our our uh our consultant
um complete the design work that's
necessary to accommodate the culvert and
then
um
and that's all going to take time
and it's going to add another six months
on so so
um I believe
um part of uh the reason for this bill
is so that
um
the town of Derry maybe I don't know
didn't have to pay the additional money
or or somebody you know wouldn't come
out of somebody else's pocket but it's
coming out of the state's pocket anyway
with a 750 000 so I I I'm unsure I'm
really unsure
roll up follow-up
so
this bill appropriates 750 000 to the
Department of Transportation to
construct the rail trail boxed Tunnel
construction project
uh
is that right
is that what it says
that's what it says okay
okay we'll work on that
any further questions from the committee
members seeing none thank you very much
thank you
next
I'll next call on Alex katrubis
for his input
good afternoon thank you Mr chair uh
most of you heard me this morning I'm
Alex katrubis I'm here representing ACC
New Hampshire American Council of
engineering companies
we're an association of about 70
engineering firms throughout the state
many of our firms work with New
Hampshire D.O.T on various
Transportation related projects roads
Bridges Traffic Safety survey and many
other Professional Services
we're here today to oppose this
legislation specifically lines three
through six which uh as we've been
discussing here would established a
Class A misdemeanor penalty on any
individual who negligently fails to
construct or impedes in any way the
completion of the rail trail box Tunnel
construction project
we believe this is a very dangerous
precedent to threaten the state
employees and as we read the bill it
would also include consultants for a
specific
uh design decisions that they're making
on Public Works projects
no one said it yet I don't think but the
class A misdemeanor I looked at the
department of safety's website
it is a jail sentence of not less than
one year
or of less than one year excuse me of
less than one year and a fine of two
thousand dollars
so that's what the penalty is uh
obviously you all know we're able to
wide 993 from Salem to Manchester we
didn't threaten anyone with a Class A
misdemeanor to get it done we we built
the Memorial Bridge we built the sour
Mildred Long Bridge we've done a lot of
really great Public Works projects
without putting a gun to people's heads
so the bill is uh as representative
Edwards and the chairman pointed out
it's it's really poorly drafted the
first sentence says any person and then
it's specifically in the next sentence
names three people so which one is it is
it any person or is it just those three
people
uh you know if the executive if by some
miracle this was to get signed into law
which I highly doubt would happen uh you
could argue that the executive Council
if they rejected the contract amendment
to build this you just heard it's going
to take a contract Amendment could the
executive Council uh you know be charged
with a misdemeanor are we going to issue
a warrant for for their arrest so it it
doesn't seem to be a pretty a really
serious attempt to uh solve this issue I
would recommend that you know the folks
who are trying to do this work with uh
Dot and try to come up with some kind of
a compromise but obviously this is this
is not the way to do it I've sent this
bill to a lot of Engineers and uh the
responses have been fairly amusing as
you can imagine I think somebody called
it a dumpster fire so I'll just leave it
at that so thank you very much uh Mr
chairman we'd obviously urge you to it
all this bill and let this project move
forward I mean the governor has said
Governor sunino had said that he
remembers going to meetings with his
father when he was governor talking
about exit 4A so that's how long we've
been talking about this thing so this is
going to you know delay it another six
months another you know and that's
probably a best case scenario so dot has
done a lot of work on this they're the
experts certainly if the legislature
were to pass a law to require this the
the engineer the consultant would follow
the direction of their client the dot
and and get them done with what they
need to get done so we don't really have
a real position on whether or not it
should be included but certainly the
penalty section is uh
really not good public policy thank you
very much
thank you for your testimony will you
take questions of course representative
Murray for a question thank you Mr
Speaker and this is quick would you
would you mind your name
sure I can give you a card apply it
easier the way you can get to lunch
any
further questions from committee members
thank you for your testimony
any other members any other people in
the audience that wishes to testify
okay representative leishman do you have
this on a schedule
would you announce it
next Tuesday at nine o'clock one o'clock
one o'clock Vision one hearing across
the hall
um
I also have quite a lengthy list of
people that have
gone online to
put messages
you'll have all them for division one if
you wish to read them they're very
similar
Catherine McDonald of dairy supports
David Topham from Salem supports
Jennifer Blaze from Windham supports
Susan woods from Concord support Abby
ivanko from Gorham supports Alex vote
from Bedford supports
Alexander Bernhard from Andover supports
Andy day from dairy support Bob
burnell's
Bob burnoff burneth from Chester
supports Caroline Morris from Sandown
supports Kathleen Stewart from
Londonderry supports Douglas Atkins from
Salem supports Elizabeth Burgess from
Deerfield supports Elizabeth Richter
from Chester supports Ernie Roy from
Nashua supports James and Jennifer
babolia from dairy support
Gene fujina from Londonderry supports
Jeffrey cream from Nashua is opposed
Jonathan normington from Windham
supports Julie grubow from Candia
supports Catherine normington
from Windham supports I think she's down
there twice
Keith Evans from Fremont supports Leif
Martinson Northfield support Mark
Connors Dairy support
Mary Ellen Stella Derry support
Michael Lucci Londonderry support
Michael McAfee Dover support
Nicole Shattuck Derry support Patricia
Anastasia Londonderry support
Paula Bedard Goffstown support Robert
spiegelman conquered support Ronald
cartright Dairy support
Claire Prince Londonderry support Dan
Watkins Dairy support
Deborah Winger Waterville Valley support
Tarina sovi Dairy support Dorsey Collins
Dairy support Ellen Kolb to Merrimack
support Hester Campbell Concord support
Jesse Medeiros Plainfield support
Jessica
stringoli Dairy support Judith Kurtz
conquered support Karen Roberts Hampton
support
Catherine delay Dairy support Katie
settings conquered support Ken Winger
Waterville Valley support Mike Banks
Salem support
Paul SEC uh secondario or sectionario
Sandown support
Richard delay Dairy support Stacy begin
Hollis support Stephen Carney
Amherst support
on the blue sheet
um
a a Pollock
from
conquered is opposed
representative Edwards uh yes sir I'm
I'm just trying to make sure I
understand our our process I I don't
recall reading all the names in past
terms and is this a new rule or is this
your effort to increase transparency and
public participation are we required to
read those or or was that your did you
exercise an option
guess you could say exercise an option
thank you sir
usually the list isn't quite as lengthy
but there might be names in there that
you know those of you that represent
those towns might want to pay attention
because you may get a call from those
people wondering did you know that I
support or oppose this bill and you'll
say yes it was it was read out in the
committee and I am aware of that thank
you very much for your call
me too
all right anything further on this bill
hearing none we will be in recess till
one o'clock when we'll be coming back to
hear about HB 49 relative to postponing
the closure of synonym youth service
center Mr Mr chair before you gamble
as the sponsor of 49 and and knowing
what it is relative to a parallel Bill
running in the Senate and the house I I
believe that we could do 49 in in 30
minutes so that you can still stick to
the two o'clock for hb50 and and if if
you recessed us until 1 30 I think
you're compliant with the rules and
you're giving everyone a chance to take
a break so my recommendation would be to
recesses to 130 for just your
consideration sir
any objection from any members
all right
anybody that shows up at one o'clock
will tell them that the
it has been recessed until 1 30. I may
open the hearing at one o'clock to
announce that just to be accurate
because that is what is posted
thank you one I will be back here at one
back here at 1 30 for house bill
49.
it's good for them to know yeah it is
she said that my son and the guy working
for me broke into her apartment
to do drugs and drink beer and they
don't do drugs or drink beer
I think
she's the one doing the drugs
environment
see if I can grow you from somewhere
well I've been on uh public works for
five terms so I'm just it's really
familiar with that
I don't know which yeah I know
absolutely were you on Ena yeah
Solid Waste issues are
bad news
you probably hear more about it see you
later
or something
they take their
their campus
okay
it being 130 it'll come out of recess we
open this hearing at one o'clock on
recess till 1 30. open the hearing on
House Bill 49 FNA call on the prime
sponsor representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair uh I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
uh Rockingham District 31
that's Auburn Candia Chester Deerfield
I'm here to introduce a house bill
49. this is an act relative to
postponing the closure of the sununu
Youth Services Center
um
I'm I'm going to ask for the chairman to
consider simply retaining this bill and
and I'll explain why uh this this is
like the little red box that you see as
you walk down the hallway it says in
case of time
uh I at this point am extremely
optimistic that this bill is is not
actually going to need to be considered
for an OTP because
um things are going very well with the
real plan the real plan that you don't
see before you today is that the house
and the Senate have been running
parallel activities to get a a complete
synonym replacement built together
in the on the on the Senate side it's
sp1 and it's been amended a couple of
times on the house side it's hb120
that's got one Amendment and I'm
introducing another one on Tuesday to
Children and Family Law
um the good news these to to me the
metaphor is we have two horses running
down uh in parallel paths we need one of
them to win and we want them to win as
quickly as possible uh because what
we're trying the crisis we're trying to
avoid is that under current law the
sununu center closes on one March
for those of you with a wristwatch one
March is like five weeks and there is no
real plan for what to do with the people
who are residents of that facility some
of them may end up having to get sent
out of state if they have to close on
one March some of them may end up going
into like a level four instead of a
level five secure facility which
increases Public
Safety chances or risks so
so we want to avoid the premature
closure of the sununu center
now why are we waiting until this term
to deal with this well because we had a
very nice compromise between the house
and the Senate at the end of last term
that got set up for a committee of
conference the committee a conference
somebody on the in the other house saw
that we
um
could could no that's a different
committee a conference story I have so
many stories uh no what what happened on
this one was on the committee conference
um the agreements going into that formal
meeting between the house and the Senate
was around capacity
and uh the speaker and the Senate wanted
a capacity of 12 operationally
with an ability to go to 18 if there was
an exurgent reason to do so Exogen I
guess
and
um and the house representative
um
decided despite assurances to the
speaker beforehand decided to go with
six instead of the 12 to 18
and that caused the committee a
conference process to collapse which
left us stuck with this legislative date
and statute of closing on one March we
we basically failed to do our job so so
this term we've been trying to Fast
Track these bills uh division three has
been invited to the children and family
law committee so that while they
formally heard that a larger replacement
bill that was predicated on the
committee conference agreement I think
we had a majority of division three at
that children and family law so the so
your committee sir is is is tracking
along with this for the most part
and I think I think we're in a really
good position
to receive the Senate version
that passed today unanimously
so so that that's a good sign it's going
to come over the house
the clerk and the speaker are talking
about it
uh the idea is that we're going to
continue to Fast Track the Senate
version of the full replacement bill
um and my proposal to the majority
leader and others was since children and
family law has heard so much of the bill
if they could forego and waive another
Committee hearing on it
then it could come straight to finance
and then we could get it onto the floor
faster and I don't know what's going to
happen on the floor
I I'm I'm I'm hopeful that given the
Senate unanimous approval of it that we
can get a majority of the house to
approve sb1 as amended
if we cannot
that's why we need a HP 49 this is the
break glass option if we can't do sb1
through the house we need to get
something to the governor you know late
February at the at the latest otherwise
we've got a uh a crisis over there in
the sununu center
and and with that I'll I'm happy to take
questions
questions from of Representative Edwards
for many of the committee members
representative Wallner for a question
so regardless
regardless with
with Bill one or house bill 120.
wouldn't it make more sense for us to
put a more realistic date on this one
because 49 probably can move along as
quickly as anything we can get it
through the floor so that the date is
more reasonable I mean right you only
give us now until June to build a
building or to get everybody moved out
so if we moved it out a couple of years
wouldn't that be
an alternative to have this at least we
would have this piece of it for sure
taken care of as the rest of it as the
other two bills move through and they
could stumble at any point okay so
representative Wallner I uh I know that
you've been following this for for years
and I I know that that your support on
what we do is really important to what
the house action is ultimately
uh I have come to believe that the best
bet to to fix the problem is to agree
with the Senate's unanimous support for
sb1 is amended and to run that up the
flagpole first and if we can't get sb1
passed
then I would see assuming this comes the
division three I could see division
three
sending it to the full finance committee
after we know the disposition of sb1 in
the house to take corrective remedial
break glass action
so I I don't know what is to be gained
by messing with sb49 because I think the
odds at this point is that we can get
sb1 and it's and it's the long-term fix
let's let's just fix it instead of
kicking the can down the road
thank you
representative Stringham for a question
um being relatively new to this issue
does sb1 address where the um current uh
Resonance of the sununu youth center
would go between March 1st and when the
new
long-term solution is is on board
um thank you thank you for the question
and the answer is yes what what what
what would happen is the sections of
current law that close it on one March
would would be repealed and in its place
it would say
here's a replacement facility that meets
the following kind of conditions and
requirements and once it's open for
business I I use the term go live in a
software term but when when we can go
live in the in the replacement facility
the residents will be transferred and at
that point the the current sununu Center
would be closed down and it would be
closed down for any new Admissions and
all the new any new activity after
opening of the new facility would be in
the new facility
to just kind of take it a little bit
further It also says that the existing
sununu Center would then go under the
control of the Department of
administrative services and would be
available for
um
I I've called it disposal somebody came
up with a smarter word that starts with
r but recycling re
Reclamation but essentially
doing something with it and and and one
of the bright ideas that I've heard in
the last 24 hours that the department
could look at is maybe taking that empty
facility that was sort of built on a on
a jail
basis maybe making that so that the
secure forensic hospital that we said
should be replaced so that we can get
Patients Out of the prison maybe maybe
it can be remodeled for that adult use
once the kids are gone I think that's a
genius idea that probably would be
worthy of discussion at some point it
was way beyond your question but the
short answer your question is yes
thank you
any further questions from the committee
members representative tolerski thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question again this is also relatively
new to me before sitting in at the child
and family law hearing earlier this week
but um
what I do know or what I believe I know
is it that a location for the new center
isn't finalized is that correct
there's two answers to that okay
the technical answer is that no the site
has not been selected yet that the
department has identified three possible
locations uh and that once the spill
gets passed uh the the formal process of
site evaluation and talking to the
communities and all of that stuff will
happen that's that's the technical
official answer
the I think the reality is is that
there's an extremely high bias towards
co-location of this with the Hampstead
Hospital so that we could potentially
through that co-location Leverage
um some of the staff at that facility
that's trained in managing mental and
Behavioral Health aspects of juveniles
so we get some leveraging of a
critically short resource which is the
the Manpower that's specialized in this
area and that we could get some other
advantages of co-location so so the
official answer is there are three sites
that will be evaluated
to be honest with you is I I think I I
think the bias and the momentum is
really heavily aimed at Hampstead and in
order to get the support of the
Hampstead senators and representatives
uh one of the Amendments that got
approved today said that they're going
to do this commission to to uh to make
sure that the community gets coordinated
with and that you know that there's an
appropriate amount of money that's going
to be transferred to compensate for the
lost property value and to compensate
for extra fire and law enforcement
so so the the bill that you're going to
see that you did not see in children and
family law because it's it's got amended
by the Senate has some additional
Provisions to ensure that the local
representation at Hampstead are happy
and the only reason they did that is
because everyone sort of knows the Open
Secret that this will probably go to
Hampstead does that answer your question
if I can have one little follow-up thank
you
well I understand all that and I
appreciate the answer I guess what
question comes to me is
what would be the normal process
to determine a location for something
this significant
um
and are we jumping over that process
by
for either the communities that may be
affected
um
or any of us who are decision makers or
are we jumping over a normal process
by pushing through I haven't seen the
Senate bill so I'm just yeah I feel
funny commenting on a bill that's not in
front of me I apologize but right I mean
the bill doesn't talk about uh the site
it talks about when there's a site here
the requirements that we won we're not
prejudging site location and and But to
answer your specific question are are we
are we jumping over process yeah
and and and I think part of it's our own
fault we were supposed to pass this bill
back in June uh and we have this one
March deadline and so uh I uh respect
the fact that the commissioner and the
director have continued to do a very
thoughtful examination of the
possibilities in anticipation that
something like the committee a
conference agreement was going to get
passed so they've been doing homework in
advanced it's just at a standing around
doing nothing right so they've got some
initial momentum and the directors here
he can speak to some of this but but I I
basically applaud it now now one thing I
I have done and what some of the
Senators have wanted to do was to
encourage the commissioner and others to
go ahead and to begin reaching out to
communicate with the potentially
affected communities because the insert
and he was causing dysfunction you know
when people don't know what's going on
rumors start you know
false allegations arise so so I so we've
been encouraging the uh the department
to begin Communications but I think they
kept their powder dry until they
actually know what the legislature and
Governor wants them to do so
yes ma'am
any further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you for your
testimony
well next call on director ribson
good afternoon
Joe ripsom director dcyf happy to see
everybody today
um I would uh be happy to take folks
questions uh agree with what
representative Edwards said in terms of
you know there are a couple moving parts
to this there is the idea around trying
to move a substantive piece of
legislation very quickly I think you
would describe this as kind of the belt
and suspenders approach of kind of the
you know what do we do just in case the
Senate did today move the substantive
piece of legislation sb1 through final
passage unanimously so I'd expect
crossover to you know occur promptly and
to have that bill over here in the house
child and family law is the division
three members now anyway
started hearing hb120 which is
representative Edwards version of a
similar Bill last week
those bills do need to pass by the end
of February lest we find ourselves in a
situation where sysc closes without an
alternative for the young folks who are
currently committed and detained there
and New Hampshire will continue to have
laws on the books requiring the
detention and commitment of kids but
will have no place to legally detain or
commit kids on that date
um
so with that you know we do support to
bill the bill to the extent that it
becomes necessary we will defer to all
of you in terms of strategy and tactics
on how and when to move that bill or not
move that bill in terms of you know
sequencing and I'll be happy to take
questions that anybody has
thank you director any questions from
the committee
saying none thank you for your testimony
I have a card for Mac Mark Cavanaugh
associate Council
and Hrs
Oh wrong Bill wrong bill
somehow it got put on top of the other
one all right do I have any more for
House Bill 49 it does not appear that I
do
okay
anything further from the committee
we'll take a look at who welt signed up
Keith cooning from Waypoint is in favor
the sheet from the online is blank
so we will
close the hearing on House Bill 49 and
it will be going to division three
and I don't believe they have a
scheduled hearing on it yet probably
waiting for that other one that's we're
waiting to come through so
I hope we all realize the importance of
this something needs to be done quickly
thank you for pointing that out
hearing is closed and we have a few more
minutes till our two o'clock and we'll
start that on House Bill 50. so anybody
I have some cards already on House Bill
50 anybody else wants to add one
business
hearing on hb50
foreign
and I'll call on representative Mike
Edgar
the sponsor
for the record my name is Mike Edgar I'm
a representative from Hampton
and uh thank you Mr chairman uh and
committee members for allowing me to
introduce
uh hb50 today this bill is relative to
payment of state of a portion of the
retirement system contribution of
political subdivisions
more plainly this bill requires a state
to pay seven and a half percent of
political subdivision employer pension
pension contributions on behalf of
teachers police and firefighters
many of you know
the history of the state reneging on its
promise to fund a portion of the
retirement program
Others May testify in more detail on the
history but a few of the low points are
in
1967 the state encouraged political
subdivisions to join a Statewide
retirement system for teachers police
and firefighters instead it would
contribute 40 percent
in 1977 State reduced its contribution
to 35 percent
2009 it was a busy year with different
amendments and things but uh it was
first was to reduce the share to 30 in
fiscal year 2010
then an amendment to reduce the state
share to 25 and physically uh 2011.
and then later uh in 2009 the amendment
to restore the state contribution to 35
percent in physical year
2012.
but in 2011 amendment to completely
eliminate the state contribution
was done and yes it actually went down
to zero
so
um last year in 2022
Renny Cushing submitted a bill similar
to ones he had submitted in the past
and this time it was for seven and a
half percent to restore to be restored
it this actually passed in the house but
the Senate
changed it
and did it only for one year
um I want to mention that in in 2022
last year uh the bill did pass the house
and it was only by bipartisan support
that it did
again towns cities and schools are asked
to join the state retirement system with
promise that the state would help defray
the employer costs
when New Hampshire retirement system was
formed in 1967 replacing four smaller
separate Retirement Systems the state
contributed 40 percent of the total
employer costs
the seven and a half percent that we
have now is only for one year and then
it reverts back to zero
since the state reneged on its promise
the political subdivisions have had to
pay for the state's share of the
employer costs much of which have been
downshifted the municipal and local
school property tax rates
please consider voting
OTP on HP 50
to partially reinstate the promise of
the state to political subdivisions
it would provide much needed relief to
political subdivisions and help offset
the need for increased property taxes
fb50 helps the average taxpayer in New
Hampshire
again thanks for giving me this
opportunity and I
assume there's gonna be some questions
thank you for your testimony uh
questions from the committee
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
in my city of Manchester
um those funds
um were very welcome and allowed us to
directly look at our our property tax
base do you agree with the fact that the
best way that the state can help towns
and municipalities to reduce their
property taxes is to in fact pass this
bill
um
I'd like to say yes
but I preface it to say there's a lot of
things that he could do to to help
property taxes but not downshifting
different things but this this is a very
to me is a very significant
um amount in issue and
I guess you could say that if they get
back to the 40 it'd even be better
questions
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question is there anything in
the bill that requires municipalities to
apply these particular funds to lowering
property tax as opposed to other
expenditures
there's nothing specifically in the bill
that would direct that it's kind of
unusual to direct
how things are going to be done that way
um
I just know that the experience that I
would have is is it it would really help
with providing the services that you
want to that hopefully wouldn't increase
your tax rate and it maybe if if you're
fortunate enough especially if you're up
to 40 we'll probably decrease it
[Music]
further questions
thank you representative you're welcome
thank you
uh is Catherine heck
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Catherine heck I represent
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and we are here to express our support
for this legislation our members have a
policy to encourage and support the
reinstatement of the state retirement
contribution I won't repeat any of the
history that you just heard and many of
you are probably familiar with that
history I will say that last year the
bill that passed for the one-time
payment using State Surplus of seven and
a half percent which gave 26.7 million
dollars back to municipalities in that
case those funds were applied on the
ms-434 and reported as Revenue therefore
decreasing taxation so for example Amer
School District received 174 thousand
dollars
or their taxpayers received that
reduction if that was because it was
reported as revenue for one example on
the town of Hampton
I believe received
164 000 according to nhrs data the town
of Guilford received sixty thousand so
that did go to reducing the tax burden
by accounting it as Revenue this bill
however does not direct those funds to
answer your question in that way it
would reduce what the budgeted amount
has to be for the municipality in this
case because it's not a reimbursement so
they would only budget 92 percent of
what they're currently budgeting so it
would come right out of the what needed
to be raised and appropriate so I do
believe it would reduce taxation because
if funds would not be having to be
raised and appropriated at the hundred
percent level should this legislation
pass
so I'm happy to take any questions
uh thank you questions from the
committee
Mr
papavichi Muller
thank you Vice chairman and thank you
for taking my question you said that
um you know the town has received 26.2
million in revenue and that led to tax
reductions but that would only be the
case if no new expenditures were made in
light of that new Revenue do you have
any data to support uh you know that the
towns just took the savings and applied
it to the property or is it an
assumption
so
these were unanticipated funds they had
to be accepted under law under RSA 3195
B so they wouldn't have been budgeted
for
so when we create our town budgets we
have the appropriation side so what
you've chosen to allow the town to spend
and then we have the revenue side so we
had to budget 100 percent of the cost
and tax people on a hundred percent of
the cost so when we receive these
payments and we reported them as Revenue
that we did not anticipate it
automatically came off the top before
the taxes were redistributed so
therefore it would reduce taxation quick
quick follow-up
follow up thank you
thank you for describing the processes
or the former Finance director for the
town of Windham I'm deeply familiar with
that and everything you said is accurate
but it is also you know known that towns
have opportunity to decide towards the
end of the year whether to spend
appropriated money or not depending on
how much money is left in the budget and
obviously new revenues coming in change
that equation this is the you know
question that I was asking whether you
you know asked or studied that or you
know is it just an assumption that
because the revenue was there and it
wasn't appropriate it must have been
savings I'm just trying to establish you
know how you arrive to that conclusion
that this is all property tax savings oh
thank thank you for your question I
appreciate that Clarity so the funds
came in in December and for many of our
calendar year towns I can speak to that
their year closed so if they're fiscal
year closed and they reported on Revenue
in December in November when the tax
rate is set they wouldn't have an
opportunity to re-spend those funds
because it would have lapsed so
therefore I do believe in many cases
that these funds directly did impact in
a very positive way property taxes thank
you thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
Gene teach
honorable Gene Dietz sorry
for the record my name is Gene dietch
and thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee for listening to my
testimony today
I'm here representing a group that I I
chair old Granite State matters
were a media organization with 4 000
members and subscribers
and our goal is to make the public aware
of how what elected officials do affects
their pocketbooks and their daily lives
so I thank you for your one-time
contribution to the group one and group
2 pension sharing last year
and for considering making that
permanent with hb50
costing about 26 million next year what
I want to suggest is that that is not
enough for your constituents
I was in ways and means on Tuesday
and uh testimony there said that New
Hampshire is first to recover in
recessions
but what they did not say is that that
recovery was based on downloading a
hundred million dollars and expenses to
towns and property taxpayers
and we've done that for at least 10
years now
that's if my my calculation almost a
billion dollars
that taxpayers
mostly taxpayer property tax funding has
lent to the state what would the bond
interest be on that payment if they had
had to borrow it if the state had had to
borrow it that's a billion dollars so
really 26 million for one year thank you
very much but that's only the start and
we really need at this point to give
towns back
what has been taken from them
on two
in Ways and Means some lawmakers had the
audacity to support a bill called HB 100
which would have taken the interest in
dividends tax to zero
they said that we don't no longer need
the 113 million dollars that that tax
would bring in if it were at the five
percent level it's traditionally been at
um were the state's doing so well that
we don't need to tax that anymore of
course that particular tax uh goes to
some is paid almost all by the top five
percent of
um dividend and interest earners in the
state
um but uh it said that we no longer need
that money
um
that 113 million would fund next year's
pensions up to about 32 percent
so shouldn't a state that's touting its
ability to quick recovery and its
excellent economy face up to the
responsibilities to municipalities
and instead of cutting taxes on those
most stable to pay
shouldn't it be at least picking up its
share of the pension burden in upcoming
years even if it never pays back the
billion
that it shirked
if you look at the sheet that I handed
out you'll see
how our population has changed
uh over the last
over the last decade
you'll see that New Hampshire families
have been forced out
our our level of school-led children has
dropped 12 and 13 percent
while our level of seniors has risen 47
percent
and my neighbors an award-winning
realtor and she tells me that it's
gotten worse since the pandemic that she
now speaks almost solely to 50 through
70 year olds and that the 30 year old
she's talking to who can afford to move
here are childless
so that's where our state's headed and
the property tax problem is part of it
as you all know it's much more
complicated than just property taxes
we've got housing and many other issues
but we can start with the property tax
so I suggest that you not only support
hb50 but amend it to return at least 32
percent in Revenue sharing to the
municipalities you represent
um and I hope that when it comes round
to HP 192 that you all support that bill
as well
I pay that tax I'm willing to continue
to pay that tax because I know that the
future of our state relies upon it
um so I assure you that Granite State
matters will be reporting
on this committee and Ways and Means
actions and I thank you for listening
uh thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
representative Edwards
uh uh thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr chair I I I just want to
make sure I understand an assertion in
any uh data that you have to support uh
something I I think I'm I'm hearing you
say that
um
because we haven't been contributing as
much as we initially promised that's
caused the flight of young people from
New Hampshire that there's a causative
action between failing to fund the
pension at promised rates and a
reduction of school-aged children to 12
to 13 percent
can you help me understand the science
behind that and what research you have
to draw that conclusion representative
Edwards you know that it's much more
complicated than that it's not I know
I'm just asking about your assertion I
will I will connect to those dots
um
the lack of funding has raised property
taxes and property taxes as we all know
are one of the issues that are facing
families trying to live here
and the fact that it's very complex the
fact that salaries
have not kept up with the increases in
costs of both property and property
taxes and everything else is part of
what's causing it's certainly not the
sole reason but we can only start to
address these things in steps and this
is a step we can take I'll just add by
the way that the 113 million is the dra
fiscal note on HB 192.
follow up so so would you believe that
we heard the Bea testify in the last
week or two on um changing demographics
to say that they are able to determine
why people are moving in the state
because they're available to survey and
ask them but that they are unable to
tell us officially the reasons why they
depart because once they leave the state
we lose the ability to survey them and
ask them and and because our own
Department can't figure it out I'm I'm
still interested in what research you
have to to to back up your assertion in
the midst of a complex situation
okay well if you look at our total and
school enrollments it's obvious that we
are losing children so there's no
question about that right and and the
Census Bureau figures show that we are
losing children now your question is why
we are losing children that's also a
complex thing uh uh people are having
fewer children but what um
what the
department is able to tell you and I'm
sure told you is that we are gaining
people from immigration and if we are
losing people
maybe of all ages though that's not what
census shows and we are gaining only
older people it's pretty obvious that we
are losing families and that uh the we
know
that the people who are coming here as
my realtor friend told you and as I'm
sure the department probably told you
are people who are quite affluent and
they have to be in order to pay the
prices and the taxes and everything
that's here so by definition if only
affluent seniors and singles can move in
and across the board people are moving
out
children are growing older they're not
being replaced that is what shows that
the lack of affordability
is an issue here there's there are two
experiments
um going on one I believe in each of our
cities in Concord and Manchester
in which they have some very affordable
housing
and by providing this a very affordable
housing they have been able to attract
some low-income families so there are
projects going on that would suggest
that it is an income factor and that we
can attract people if we can get our
prices down and as I say this is just
one step
and it's a step that we can take by not
cutting
the IND
ucing that money toward this end
uh further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Marine Mueller
hello good afternoon Marie Mullen
Director of Finance from the New
Hampshire Retirement System
um we have a handout coming out here for
a bill brief from the retirement system
first I'd just like to state that the
retirement system neither supports nor
opposes this legislation we're merely
here to attest to the facts on the
Actuarial report that we have received
for the legislature
so um as you've heard on the testimony
this bill requires state pay seven and a
half percent of the political
subdivision employer pension
contributions on behalf of teachers
police officers and firefighters
um
the retirement system received an
independent actuary estimate from our
actuaries GRS
and we estimate that the political
subdivisions employer contribution costs
on behalf of the teachers police
officers and firefighters would be
reduced by
approximately 26 million in 2024 27
million in 2025 and almost 28 million in
and the cost to the state would increase
by that amount
um and this would be in perpetuity so
those costs would be
um savings to the municipalities going
forward and costs to the state past 2026
this analysis only went to 2026.
the bill does not impact the unfunded
liability the unfunded Actuarial
liability with the retirement system
because it does not change the total
amount of the employer contributions
we've provided some additional
background which I think the other folks
have already testified to and I would
just open it up to any questions that
anyone may have
uh questions like many oh my goodness
representative Hawkins Phillips thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um so I served in a previous uh life as
a member of the Hanover finance
committee and I recall in several
meetings that the the topic of the opeb
came up quite a bit and I was just
wondering if you could maybe be speak a
little explanation explainer for those
who are watching at home who may not
know could you speak to that unfunded
Actuarial accrued liability and talk
about what that concept means for the
folks at home okay
um
so what this is is we have the actuaries
so we have census data so we estimate
the number of retirees what their wages
are going to be what the investment
earnings will be in the fund and we
project out into the future
over a 30-year period how much will be
needed to fund and continue to pay the
pensions and the other pension
liabilities of the municipalities the
state police and fire
um
so the unfunded liability is that
portion
that's identified from what has we have
for Investments
plus what we bring in from employers and
then what the employees pay towards
their retirement that difference is the
unfunded liability So currently that's
approximately 5.7 billion dollars of
unfunded liability
further questions
uh yes sir Mr Bobby Miller
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
this is not one of those questions where
I can kind of guess the answer is so I
really don't know this
um
I've hired actuaries but I'm not sure
exactly how do they do their magic it
tends to be rather opaque is there any
way to look at Actuarial data and try to
see whether
changing who pays for the retirement
fund whether a larger share is paid by
the state or by the municipalities has
an impact on the wages and benefits the
total compensations paid by the towns
um I am not sure if we've done
um a study or had had the actuaries do
that before that's something I could go
back and
and look into and find out I would
appreciate at least knowing whether
that's a question they could answer
hypothetically because I really don't
know whether they could but thank you if
you could follow up it would be
appreciated can you just repeat that
question I would just like to know
whether actuaries have the ability to
determine whether a change in who pays
whether the state base or the
municipality pays different shares
changes the total amount of compensation
paid by the towns depending on you know
whether they are fully responsible or
they are only partly responsible for the
retirement contributions I'm just
looking for scientific data you know one
way or the other
okay thank you
representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair I I I don't know
if uh the department has thought about
taking a position on this but if we
could only do one thing which thing do
you think would uh benefit our our bond
ratings more and improve the stability
over all of the Pension funds
a uh having State money replace local
money keeping the total liability the
same or instead taking whatever money
the state might have contributed that
way and directly reducing the accrued
liability which which one would
strategically be a better economic
choice
um
then I will just state that the
retirement system does not have a
position and maybe we could talk offline
about that but I'm not prepared to
provide an opinion on that so
representative
very much and thank you for taking my
question
um could you just
give us a little bit of a synopsis of
the history of when this commitment was
made to the towns and whether towns
acted in Reliance on the commitment by
the state to pay 40 percent of the
retirement costs in developing their
retirement programs
um I will say I'm not an expert on this
many of you may remember I was
previously with Department of
Transportation so I've been with
retirement for four months
um the background on our our sheet here
is some of the background that we're
aware of so
um I'm I'm not in the position to
provide a lot of the background at this
time but we can get that for you our Pio
is out ill and that's why I'm testifying
today so I apologize for the lack of
background for you
follow up
um well I'm a new member of finance and
a lot of folks may know the history of
the uh where this promise came from and
why and who relied on what and I think
it's interesting as we look at the
amount of contribution that's expected
to know what representations were made
to the town when it first came into
place
so thanks for following up on it okay
uh further questions
thank you for your testimony okay thank
you
it
is representative O'Brien here
thank you uh Mr chair uh representative
Mike O'Brien uh represent the city of
Nashua ward nine uh besides let's do the
usual caveats uh I am a State Rep I am
also vice president of the board of
alderman in the great city of Nashua and
I'm also the other helmet that I wear is
a retired Deputy fire chief so I have a
fair to middle and understanding of the
pension system and I can take you a
little bit down the road of you know the
pension system
basically prior and I don't want to you
know take too much time so if I do
please stop me this is difficult for an
Irishman to speak quickly but anyways in
the early late 60s I should say they
came an idea that took four different
pension groups and to combine them into
one and they gave the options to the
cities and towns and joining it and they
made a certain promise and this is what
you might hear as the promise made as a
promise kept but they came up and said
for joining into the New Hampshire
retirement system we'll pay 40 percent
that was the original agreement
past legislatures came in and changed it
from 40 to 35 percent that remain in
effect
from
1968 until 2011. you say what is the
problem with the New Hampshire
retirement system I'll tell you directly
and let me be blunt the problem with the
retirement system is 400 state
representatives
in other words when you put money away
into a pension system it's not to be
played with every biennium
and this is why we ended up right here
to what is the problem in 2011 certain
Cuts were made
can't go out and blame the employees
when I started in the fire service my
contribution as an employee was 93
quarter percent when I left I was paying
11.85
so the employees are making up the bulk
of the the system there was holidays
that's became the unfunded liability
another problem but what's before you
write here in house bill 50 does not
affect the unfunded liability
has nothing to do with it whatsoever
that will still be paid by the
municipalities but what's happening to
municipalities it's because of the
cutback the 35 percent at the State of
New Hampshire paid vaporized well you
know
what bank will make any type of loan or
a commitment or contract to vaporize you
don't so where did that go back that
went right back to the local taxpayers
who have people in the New Hampshire
retirement system let's face it you
could call it what you want you could
put lipstick on the pig but it's a tax
in other words the missing of that 35
contribution by the state came out to be
born by the taxpayers of many of the
communities in the example of Nashua
this comes down annually to about two
million dollars two million dollars in
the city of Nashua comes down to
basically one percent of the tax rate so
that means one percent of the tax rate
is being paid
to make up the difference of the Cabbage
of not paying the 35 percent
this is I would say a very moderate way
of looking at it nobody's coming in and
saying re-establish to 35 percent
but they're coming in brutally
and saying why don't we do a quarter of
it 7.5 percent
and try to alleviate to cities and towns
and that's where the two million dollars
for the taxpayers of Nashua will come
from let's look at Nashua again we
fought the covert battle
we have
veterans housing we have Workforce
housing I'm glad Nashua has brought
shoulders to help out people in our
communities that are less unfortunate
than I am but the thing is it does come
and when money's being shipped out to
the pension system unnecessarily because
what did this really fix really not much
I mean look at it who gained from it all
you have to do is you're in finance look
at the uh
the Surplus that the state has right now
so therefore you know and then let's
look at the Surplus again over the years
other great things have happened
gambling keno and different other things
have added into the Surplus quarters so
we're prudently asking seven and a half
percent to come through now this was
heard last year in the various forms of
similar form in the house and it was
passed
and it went to the Senate and it passed
the Senate except of the difference was
being annually disena cut it down to one
year and only one year only
hey it will it's better than nothing
but this would really help the
municipalities each cities and towns if
this was an annual benefit that they
could come on those of you that wear the
two hats like I do know when you're
trying to do a municipal budget it's
very difficult
very difficult how much snow we're going
to get what type of plow truck needs to
be replacing a fire truck or something
like that out of Capital Improvements at
least this will get this going pretty
quickly and something that you know you
can count on with that
so in essence I'm going to wrap it up at
that you know and take any type of
questions but I would like this that has
a positive I would like to see a
positive recommendation not on my behalf
but this should be fully vetted by all
members of the House on the floor and to
come up and exactly what happened in the
last session and overwhelming support
this this bill here of
Genesis of what happened in the last
term the last term Bill had bipartisan
support
it made it to the Senate
and I feel
in my heart that if you support this
bill this will again will come up with a
positive recommendation from the floor
and make it over to the Senate side to
be determined so at that I'll end my
comments and available for uh any type
of questions if you may have them
any questions on the committee
representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
representative O'Brien I I'm I'm I'm not
a real academic when it comes to the
retirement system so I'm going to share
with you something I've heard hallway
banter some paranoia and let you educate
me what what I've heard is that the
concern is if we were to take Nashville
just as your example you've offered them
and the state went ahead and filled in
that two million dollar hole or whatever
is being spent
that Nashua would likely take that 2
million and increase spending elsewhere
and that the new spending would be done
in a way in which the state legislature
would have no influence and so we would
basically the the fear and then I'm just
looking for how you react to this is the
the fear is that this money is basically
you know bankrolling more local spending
that by and large the state would have
no voice in
well you got to remember uh let's look
historically at it prior to 2011 was
that the case
you know in other words this change came
in 2011.
so prior to 2011 there wasn't uh you
know any great parties being thrown down
at City Hall or anything else like that
and I say that lightly but it's not just
Nashua and I would like to say I'm sure
that Catherine miss Catherine heck of
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
which does support this I got this she
from the last time I fought this
familiar battle
Nashville is only one of the cities and
towns that are involved with this this
many others that will economically
benefit from this so if you ask the
question in the example of Nashua it's
true for a lot of political subdivisions
within the state now again is there some
things in Nashua that needs attention
yeah Welcome to our budget process every
single year I have to I sit on the
budget committee I have to sit down and
pick and choose in certain things that
need to be done can we get another year
out of that pickup truck
or not
you know when we look at the Capital
Improvements we looked at many other
different things such as in Nashville
we're very prudent with a dollar I have
to say we've looked at bonding maybe the
station look at bonding but we looked at
bonding as an issue to purchase a fire
truck they're going for about a half a
million dollars plus
and we'll Bond over the life of that
vehicle and it turns out to work pretty
good and natural I'll have you say
I'm very proud of it fiscally we have a
from standard and poor AAA Bond rating
that's pretty good and done good for any
municipality and may I also say to
reverb
back to reserve back to what I say with
the pension system I forgot to mention
our Board of Public Works they chose at
that particular time not to get into the
New Hampshire retirement system I said
on that board as well too that pension
board is 87 percent funded
how come naturally can do it in the
state of New Hampshire can't
again it's 400 people sticking their
fingers in the pot did you know in your
time when you grew up
when you had the Odin update myself but
you remembered the old uh whatever they
used to call that the Christmas he used
to put money away for Christmas and you
save it well you know if you didn't make
the money the kids didn't get the toys
for Christmas this is the same thing
with the pension system that money
should have been away properly invested
and should not have been played with and
to leave it alone and again we're paying
for that mistake in the past I I know I
over answered your question so I
apologize
oh absolutely
so thank you so so the way I'm going to
store your answer and you can correct me
if I've got this wrong is that if if in
the case of City acts which may be
Nashua that we may help with the two
million dollars then yes there are high
priority spending needs that aren't
currently being met that Nashville would
identify and probably spend some portion
of the two million dollars on that
that's what I think I heard you say I
don't want to assume that that's what
you meant why yeah I cannot guarantee
that some of that money may go to some
other funds to assist but you explain I
would ask the question but I cannot ask
and nor to debate and not intending so
but in the i in my Irish form I will say
what is wrong idealistically with the
state of New Hampshire helping out its
second largest city
uh further questions
uh thank you for your time oh would I
miss one
are you sure
thank you for your testimony well thank
you very much and thank you for having
me and I'm going back to uh to see the
other representative McGuire now to
better look at one
thank you all thank you
uh representative Weiler
oh
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
I oppose this bill
it puts in Jeopardy all the work
that this committee does to create a
budget
that will sustain our state for two
years and we do this three months before
the biennium begins
we can safely say that the revenue that
our budget depends on has been
accurately forecast by Ways and Means
for the last several biennia
we then make a budget that stays within
that revenue forecast
this bill proposes spending that this
legislature has absolutely no control
over
yet requires us to make those payments
regardless
I cannot accept this for responsible
budgeting
nor can I accept this
constant claim you promised you promised
we always say that the promise is only
as good as the present biennium budget
nothing goes beyond that unless it's a
bond
what we decide to spend in this next
budget that's what we spend and we can
tell every other
agency in this state that uses our money
this is all you can spend
if there's some Surplus and they come
back to us later maybe we give them more
money but this doesn't even allow us
that option whatever it costs that's
what it is
ten years ago I was responsible in this
finance committee when we had to cut the
budget
10 percent
to look at what was happening with this
contribution to municipality retirements
they had grown like crazy
we hear about oh you promised in 68.
well I remember in 70 when small towns
like mine and the one next to us had no
people in this Retirement System
nobody
we began to hire people in the 70s for
full-time jobs that didn't exist when
this agreement was first made to bring
everybody into it there were very few
employees so at the time we decided to
take it out of the budget in the 1213
budget
it was going to be 60 million dollars
if you
projected this cost for seven and a half
percent it would now be 124 million in
10 years
can we afford this kind of increase year
over year that we have no control over
that's not the way we can make a budget
we can decide to give the money year
after year
but
we do that in a specific amount this is
how much you're going to get
and there were two things that I'm
delighted to see thank you for the
municipal Association you all got mail
this
it tells you in the back on page 23 the
revenue sharing
so two troubling obvious
misrepresentations in this bill
first we know that is only a foot in the
door attempt to raising the rate of
contribution to 35 percent that existed
before 2010. and I will remind you again
all this crying about oh you raised the
property taxes by doing that no we
raised the contribution by the employee
by two percent you heard that admitted
by representative O'Brien we raised by
two percent and a little bit more for
the firemen and the police
as it stands still even at 11.8 Pi 11.8
of whatever he's contributing
his the
Firehouse
the town is contributing like 19 or 20
percent now most Retirement Systems that
you know about you are fortunate if the
employer matches what the employee puts
in we're putting in most cases two and a
half times
that's not reasonable
I think if the retirement system is in
trouble and we've passed bills in 2011
to try to fix it
it was a two billion dollar deficit in
2011 when we did that now it's 5.7 how
did that work out yes the 400 people in
this house because they keep changing it
to make it worse as far as the money in
that in that fund because oh no we're
not going to make the rules that we put
in 2011 to fix this we don't like them
because these people are upset by those
rules so we're going to change them okay
so we're never going to catch up with
the deficit and it will continue to grow
but taking this money
from our other funds and putting it
toward the towns and trying to make it
forever or even to raise the 35 percent
is going to make a headache for every
future
finance committee that's coming after us
because it's totally unpredictable we're
coming around to hear everybody saying
well we ought to raise all the employees
eight nine ten percent because of
inflation
what's that going to do that's also
going to raise the contribution the
state makes
if the state has to make that and it's
unpredictable we know how much we'll
have in this budget if we have to raise
money to pay our employees and we'll put
it in the budget and we'll find the
money and we'll have to make reductions
elsewhere but
I'm offended very much by property tax
reduction act what a joke
we're given 1.3 billion back to the
towns
this is going to give 27 million
a drop in the bucket
on your budget on your property taxes
here you'll have a hundred million off
of the swept tax
I'm thinking that's going to amount to a
couple hundred dollars per tax bill
for the average tax bill
this would amount to maybe a fourth of
that maybe fifty dollars
for the average tax bill you think
anybody's going to get excited about
that
that's going to be lost in rounding and
normal tax increases you'll never see
that reduction
it's not enough to make a fuss about and
put in a bill and tell lies about oh you
promised or you stole it
they forget that the difference in in
the 1213 budget is that we
made up the loss to the towns by the
employee
so if you look at this this will tell
you the history
of Revenue sharing from the state to the
towns it's growing growing growing it's
been 1.3 billion like I say in here
over a billion dollars for education
programs Highway grants another 110
million
share the rooms and meals taxes up to 95
million environmental programs that can
conclude include flood control landfill
state aid grants to Water Systems and so
on another 15 million
are they unaware of this when they claim
this is the property tax reduction act
this is a joke
vote no totally unnecessary it destroys
all the work that we try to do as a
finance committee I'll be happy to take
any questions
uh thank you for the testimony any
questions
representative Edwards uh think thank
you Mr Mr chair but um so so in in your
testimony you you
use the word lies I I I don't think you
intended to impugn the motives or
Integrity of any of the sponsors so do
you do do you want to do you want to
clarify that sir I take it back thank
you for that it's a misrepresentation
are we all have different opinions on
what things move different ways and I
think more of us here know what happens
economically when we move things around
the budget other members that are not
involved in the budget may not know as
much thank you yes sir thank you for
that I I know you and I I don't I I knew
that you didn't intend to do that so
then my real question uh if I may is
um as I as I look at the retirement
system this is now the beginning of my
fourth term I have no clue why New
Hampshire hasn't done what the rest of
the United States has done by moving
away from a defined benefit retirement
program and moving into a 401k kind of
arrangement or whatever the right
letters are for the government
equivalent 401b or I don't know so
because you have so much history on this
could you could you please educate
people on what has been the problem with
doing the obvious that all the other
states are doing uh going from Define
benefit retirement to a contributory
benefit program
well I would say it's the unions they
can generate hundreds of phone calls and
letters
they don't ever look at it economically
they just look at what they want
and we have a lot of Republicans that
will go along with it and a lot of
Democrats that will go along with the
unions so they end up getting a majority
in cases even when the Republicans have
the majority they get a majority that
Tinkers with the retirement system
because the union thinks it's to their
advantage and obviously if we're now 5.7
billion in the whole from 2 billion 10
years ago that tinkering has not been to
the advantage
of the Union people
what I foresee is at some point since
the retirement system is off budget
if it keeps growing in this deficit we
declare bankruptcy
divvy up how much money is in there for
each person that's in the retirement
system and said from now on that's your
defined
contribution you can add to it all you
want and we'll add so much a year about
the same as we've done but there's no
way we can make up a deficit that's just
about the same size as the whole state
budget
thank you oops so mayor I I I I I I
think the bankruptcy your uh issue
you're you're thinking of is the worst
case scenario uh and not anyone's plan
but on the projected course that may be
what a future legislature faces it may
be there maybe maybe you know the other
choice and I know other states have done
that
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Weiler for taking my
question I'd like you to compare two
similar
cases suppose that this committee does
its job very well and we find that we
have an extra 25 million dollars uh per
year available to fund something like
this all right and let's also suppose
that if we were to fund house bill 50
that the towns would return 100 of what
they received back to their own
taxpayers their own property tax where
they don't spend any extra let's let's
skip off skip that example right that's
one alternative
now suppose in the other alternative we
cut the state property tax by that same
amount that same 25 million dollars a
year right we're collecting
363 million dollars worth of property
tax we could easily cut 25 a year right
so wouldn't the difference between those
two
be that towns that budget themselves
very tightly and keep tight control over
the number of employees they have and
are thrifty
would get less
uh relatively less than towns that are
relatively generous or expansive in
their hiring
and so effectively if you live in a town
that has uh is Thrifty and has good
budgeting wouldn't you be subsidizing
those other towns that have expansive
hiring
the answer is yes and one of the things
we discovered years ago
when we first put this Statewide
education property tax was we had donor
towns we fought that for 10 years
because they were very upset at all this
money game that they were paying in
taxes going to other towns
that didn't have the same tax basis
so we stopped doing that and we let them
keep everything and in some cases now
with the decline in enrollment that
Statewide education property tax in some
towns
is bringing in more money than they need
to educate their students so if we cut
directly the Statewide education
property tax it makes more sense in
those towns ahead more than they needed
to spend which would be another good
thing I agree
further questions the representative
Hull
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
to your earlier point about this is this
act is being titled the property tax
relief of 2023. it's my understanding
that this is not a single year change
but A multi-year change is that correct
it appears to be yes follow up follow
follow up thank you
um if I understand our constitution
correctly right article part one article
um no pension shall be granted but in
consideration of actual services and
such patients ought to be granted with
great caution by the legislature and
never for more than one year at a time
would be we would we be in compliance
with our constitution if we did a
multi-year
it would require us annually or at least
biannually to keep renewing that yes
that's why I say there was no problem
when we took it away in the 1213 budget
thank you
any further questions
uh representative Hewitt
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
I don't want to get into into all all
the arguments that are going back and
forth
excuse me because that's going to be
going on for quite a while and we all
know that
but I just want to focus on one question
that has been completely ignored since
the since the beginning
and that is that
it was in 1967 or so
that the state
made the decision that it probably
didn't want to have four individual
Retirement Systems floating around
and so they've had to find a way to make
it work better
and that eventuated in the arrival of
the cities and towns
uh whom all of whom were approached by
the state
and the state approached the cities and
towns and said how would you like to
join a State Retirement System
and
any any politician will say well I don't
want to do that right off the top of my
head we all we all like that but
what they said was well
what's in it for me
and the state responded well what's in
it for you is that we'll pay 40 percent
of the cost of doing this
and they said yes and the retirement
system was was born
and the retirement system continued
pretty much the same I've looked at all
the laws and I wasn't too much that
happened other than you know nickel and
dime stuff to adjust one thing or
another
uh until 2010 2011 in which the state
decided well we're not going to do this
anymore
I think that's wrong
and I don't think that any of the
arguments have been made have anything
to do with that they have to do with
spending of money by the sounds and by
the state
and it has nothing to do with the people
who do the work
do you do you agree that that the form
the uh formation of the retirement
system as it exists today was made in
1967 by the state and the communities
getting together and establishing it
I agree and there have been many
offerings since at the time that we're
not that many
different groups offering Retirement
Systems we hear a lot about Tia Cref Tia
Cref and I think the the university
system is in that system and I think
there are other groups within the state
that are in alternative Retirement
Systems so everybody is free to do that
so you know you look where you get the
best rate where you get the best results
and you could probably change the thing
you could probably withdraw the money
that you put in
and get into a new system
so it's entirely possible
further questions
thank you representative for your
testimony
oh geez let me do with that sheet
thank you
Mr chair
yes sir I'd like to say something
go ahead
I am not used to being called a liar
and when I am I would normally take care
of it in a different ways and mentions
to you right now
but if anybody wants to say that
anything on this sheet is a lie then I
like to talk to him there's no lies here
there's a couple opinions there's almost
all facts
and I like to actually make a lot of
other comments right now on some
previous testimony but uh but I won't
because I know that's not the uh the way
it's normally done here
thank you
yes sir
representative sorry
thank you Mr chair representative Mike
O'Brien again
uh as you know
and watching the pension system I can
see if I can grab it
but in the uh Wall Street Journal
the question was asked by this committee
what about a 401k
you got to remember we went through the
dot com era
where you worked
in a particular corporation IBM let's
say for the example and then your
friends came up and said how long you've
been working for IBM five years aren't
you a go-getter why don't you try Wang
and you went to Wang and maybe get a
vice president's job but you needed
something in your briefcase to take with
you from job to job to job for your
pension
and that's where the 401K came from
now the difference with the defined
benefit program keep in mind
we want each municipality spends
thousands of dollars
training firefighters and police
officers we want them to stay
but right now there's a recruitment
issue it's a problem we have other
municipalities and Nashua does it too we
raid out the Departments to get them to
come in and it's almost like who's
offering good benefits or anything else
like that there is a definite retention
problem we're hearing it right now in
Edna
from many departments so part of the
problems that are coming up and getting
people to work in this type of field is
problems with the retirement system
so supporting this bill would have to
fix but to get back to the Wall Street
Journal article the inventor of the 401K
did write it and if the committee wishes
I'll see if I can find it
and to have it reprinted and give it to
the committee but he has deep regret in
inventing the 401K let's keep in mind
the government gives you the high end
but doesn't do anything if you make less
payments so what's going to happen to
the generation that decided to buy the
vote the vote or the car or something
like that instead of putting the maximum
amount into the pension system that's
the beauty of a defined benefit
the employees cannot touch that fund
that is there forever and it's supposed
to go in there and again don't touch it
let it grow let one dollar bill meet
another dollar bill and make five dollar
bills that's the intention of any
pension program that didn't happen here
or else we wouldn't be here discussing
this
okay so the thing is the 401K is not
really the right answer to look at this
and particularly for the recruitment
issue but if you want that information
I'll try to find it
and Supply to this committee but he the
author of the 401K has regret
it could have been something better
thank you
we take a question
oh absolutely I never miss an
opportunity I guess I didn't need to ask
that I representative policeman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
representative O'Brien I know you're not
shy to voice your opinion
so as you know and most of us around the
room know that there's between like a
300 and 400 million dollar Surplus and a
lot of folks are asking for a piece of
that
and of course the committee is going to
have to decide whether we're going to
make one-time contributions towards some
of these requests or they're going to be
ignored until the next session so
there's another bill maybe you're going
to stick around to speak on it but
suggestions have been made that we
either make a one-time contribution
towards the retirement system of the 7.5
or maybe we take some of that Surplus
and go towards the unfunded liability do
you
like that particular proposal if you had
to choose one or the other and I know
you'll
be honest with me with that yeah thank
you representative leishman because I
have had this conversation with his
honor the mayor James donches of Nashua
and he would like to see the Standalone
of this whether going to the unfunded
liability uh yes in 2039 the unfunded
liability okay and this this is how
things happen
there's no guarantee at the end of 2039
that the unfunded liability will be met
if they're telling you it is they're
lying to you you'll be substantially
paid off but then again coming up with
the unfunded liability what's the
benefit what's the cost benefit analysis
remember I told you that in the uh
Municipal Public Works pension system
that the city's in charge of hok and how
come says that to be 87 funded in
another group says we're almost like 92
percent funded that's darn good compared
to other pension systems that are around
right now I I think we're probably
you've got to have to ask New Hampshire
retirement system but some of the
changes that were done were to the
better but did some things we we are a
little bit better off I think the
municipalities would like to see the
money come back to them that they can
decide basically on what to do with the
dollars because it comes down to all
other things encompassing uh you got to
remember municipalities when you're in
charge of a city
you are not supposed to make a buckle
what is our product we don't sell
widgets
we're supposed to provide a quality of
life
for our constituents
that means plow the roads salt them when
it snows everything else educate the
children
if there's a fire have a fire department
if there's a crime rate have a
substantial Police Department our job is
people
when you take the mantle and municipal
government
and when you can't get policemen to come
in and work particularly the largest
cities Manchester and Nashua who wants
to get puked on spin on and kicked
around the universe
none of us do
but you got to keep in mind that old
adage that used to say well the job
stinks but the pennies were good
now the job still stinks in the Benny
stink
so this is the recruitment problem
so you got to look at the whole thing
but I know I over answered my family did
KISS the Blondie Stone before we left
thank you
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um on February 15th I'll be bringing a
defined contribution Pension Plan Bill
to your committee and I hope to convince
you to support it specifically because
it removes the 400 representatives from
from the control of the system when
people get their money they get it right
away and it's theirs and there are no
changing it by the by the
representatives later all the problems
we've talked about but I would
appreciate if you would find the article
that you mentioned and get it to me
sometime prior to that day yes yes I
will uh it was supplied to me and I
can't say what I'm going to do with your
particular bill I haven't seen it yet I
will read it I firmly believe every
promise I make I keep
please send the article to Janet so that
yes for a distribution and please you
know I gotta ask a friend of a friend to
get this you know I mean so
I will try hard
further questions no
okay
um thank you for your testimony your
second testimony
is there any further
uh testimony but like to give to the
committee
okay
so on the blue sheets
Catherine heck probably well we know
that John John Cloutier Pro David Cody
Pro Brian real Pro
and Brian Hawkins Pro and from the white
sheets I won't read through the whole
thing excuse me but they are all
available online along for anybody to
access along with all the testimony that
was submitted online and thank you all
for for coming
and we thought I will
end the hero
foreign
you want your wife is retiring yes you
speaking
oh okay
okay no problem
I want to talk about
um
what we thought okay it's after three
and just keep the ball rolling I'll open
the hearing on
hb55
and is representative
growly here goalie
good afternoon Mr chair
for the record representative Jeff goli
representing Hillsboro district 21
Manchester Ward 1.
and I'm here to uh
try and be the follow-up of that act you
just had before you it's going to be
tough to follow
so I'm here today to introduce House
Bill 555 FNA and
um what this build does as you've all
heard a lot about the retirement system
and what's going on over there currently
um with the unfunded liability
and what this bill would do is
take 75 percent of any of the amount
left over after the rainy day fund is
filled and apply it to the pension fund
unfunded Actuarial accrued liability
and
in doing so we look at it as paying off
our debts and the sooner we pay off our
debts
the better off the taxpayer is going
forward I mean this is a way of directly
reducing
the tax rates for cities and towns
over 80 percent of their pension costs
are going directly towards the unfunded
accrued liability so the quicker we can
get this paid off
the sooner the sooner we pay it off the
sooner they get rate reductions and
we're looking at that as an important
tax relief bill
um
when when you go when you go forward and
you heard
I think previously I wasn't here for the
beginning of the testimony as to how we
acquired the unfunded accrued liability
it was over a number of years of not
properly funding the system
and
folks may say well why are we paying
help paying off that unfunded liability
well as many of you know or have heard
that it was because of some of the
legislation passed here by us that
caused that unfunded accrued liability
because we did not address it at the
proper time and let it Fester over for
over 10 years without changing the rates
back to where they should be
so I think it's important that we step
up to the plate and help if we have a
surplus and that's only if we have a
surplus not coming out of a regular
budget that we use Surplus money to pay
off the debt
and also as
the that is and this is only this amount
is only going through as long as we have
that debt which is you've heard is
on Pace to be paid off in 2039 I think
by doing what we're doing here we could
pay it off quicker so once that's paid
off this
peace will no longer be necessary so
with that I'd be happy to take any
questions I know there's a few other
folks behind me here to talk more about
this
thank you for your testimony
representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I generally like the idea of
paying your debts so I'm generally in
favor of this but I'm I am curious about
implementation
this past term we had a special project
we we saw the need to create a
settlement fund worth 100 million
dollars to pay for previous liabilities
to make whole abuse people in our penal
system
would would this
prevent having that option on the
Surplus
um would would this 75 percent over and
above the the rainy day fund
would this tire hands if we got another
special project that we needed to fund
which would have precedence
that's a good question
um
to be honest with you I cannot answer
that right now off the top of my head um
and someone behind me can answer that
I'm hearing all right thank you and I
ever and and also the 75 is obviously a
starting point and if this committee so
chooses to reduce that amount at any
amount uh but we just think it's
important that we put that at the
Forefront of paying off our debts yes
sir
um man
and and then this this feels to me like
a bill that's begging for a sunset
provision that that this gets repealed
at some point if we ever pay off the uh
accrued liability and I'm not I'm not
seeing a repeal like that
should it have one
I believe the way the legislation is
written that once that liability is paid
that no other money goes to well if you
have no unfunded accrued liability then
there's no place to pay it all right
that's logical thank you thank you
any other questions uh representative
Mooney thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh perhaps
you representative or representative
McGuire could give an example using
monetary amounts would be helpful in
terms of envisioning this because it's
quite intriguing thank you I think
representative inquire behind me is
shaking his head he will perfect thank
you
uh further questions for this Witness
let's see none thank you thank you
testimony
Mr Mr Kavanaugh
is that am I saying that correctly
my name is Mark Cavanaugh I'm associate
Council and compliance officer with the
New Hampshire Retirement System
uh typically when I sit in this chair we
don't take positions policy matters but
in this case we're going to make an
exception and we're in support of any
bill that's going to give us more money
and help us with the underfunding
we have an amortization plan where about
uh
18 years into it
um
and it's like a mortgage and this bill
would be analogous to paying down some
of your principal of your mortgage ahead
of time
and we think that's a good idea uh it
depending on the amounts which are
totally unpredictable so we couldn't put
a dollar on it
that would have the effect of reducing
the underfunding which would then have
the effect of possibly reducing employer
contributions in the future
I with that I'd take any questions
representative
sorry thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking the question would
it be possible for nhrs to prepare you
know like
we could ask from a mortgage company
since we use that example a schedule
showing that if we put so many millions
of dollars at the end of this year the
estimate is that this will cut this
total amount of payments including debt
and it will accelerate the uh you know
ability to pay for it we understand it
wouldn't be guaranteed because all those
assumptions change but I'm just looking
for numbers consistent with your current
assumptions basically in the same model
what difference would it make it it
would probably help
decide policy decisions in terms of how
best to spend the money when we see how
much we may save in the future versus
other types of legislation
um right well our actuaries have looked
at it and at this point there's just too
indeterminate to to put a number on it
and uh and also we use our actuary for
these matters in response to particular
bills that ask for particular things we
don't just do hypotheticals
um it because we're we're the plan we're
not the plan sponsor so we shouldn't be
assisting or paying the planned sponsor
to make policy decisions about how a
plan should be designed
uh or implemented those are what they
call plant sponsor costs and you
shouldn't be using uh money that's set
aside to pay benefits both under federal
law and under our uh Constitution that
says those assets of the plan are to be
used for the exclusive benefit of the
members
um
but if you give me a call I can
recommend an actuary for you who might
do it thank you
further questions uh representative
tolarski thank you very much thank you
for taking my question
um could you just give me an idea and I
hope I understand the concept correctly
the percentage that a municipality pays
that's directed just towards the
unfunded
um amount and how much it's about 75 to
80 percent of the employer portion of
the contributions
so we have employee contributions and
employer contributions
we have the normal cost which is the
cost of the benefit that is accruing
this year
for each individual
all of the member contributions go
towards that normal cost
the employer contribution and that picks
up about three quarters of the normal
cost the employer contribution picks up
the remainder of that normal cost and
all of the underfunding
and of their rate about 75 to 80 percent
of what they pay goes to the
underfunding and 20 25 goes to the
normal cost so the idea being that at
some point in the future when the
underfunding is paid down then you're
only paying the normal cost and an
employer contributions would be a
quarter a quarter of what they are now
but that's down the road quite a bit
thank you that answers my question
you're welcome
any further questions
representative Edwards I I thank you Mr
chair I I that's fascinating so
um
so to the extent that we can accelerate
the payoff of the unfunded liability on
that celebration date
the municipalities and other payers
they they get an enormous benefit from
being able to reduce their payments
correct that's what I think I heard you
say yeah and it's not a cliff they don't
have to rates are going to gradually go
down as we get closer and closer to
being fully funded okay so that was
going to be my question I mean is it is
it because you're on this Actuarial
decline path if we are beating your plan
do the municipalities benefit as
progress is being incremental progress
is being made over time yes rates are
reset by the actuary every two years
based on evaluation that's done every
two years so for instance the rates that
are going into effect on July 1st were
set two years ago
uh in anticipation based on an Actuarial
study from several years ago we'll do a
new Actuarial study uh this year in
reset rates next summer
um
for the next biennium rather and the new
rates going into effect in July are
lower than the current rates so when
this plan was put into place the way it
was designed and understood is that in
the beginning rates were going to go up
but at some point you're going to hit a
break-even point
and they're going to start going down
and we believe that break-even point is
this year barring
things that can affect that with like
changes in demographics or a stock
investment crash with that a huge a huge
stock market crash like 08 would add to
the underfunding and push out the date
yeah I I appreciate your answer thank
you sir
further questions
uh representative Petrie
thank you Mr chairman uh
see two thousand uh what 10 I guess the
uh
we were in trouble so the liability has
gone down to around 4.99 billion is that
the stock market fluctuations causing it
to go back into 5.7 uh well a couple of
things have affected that since the plan
first went into effect
um
one is yeah the stock market you know
the crash in 08
increased the underfunding
um because you obviously didn't meet our
expectations as to investment earnings
in addition uh
we do other Actuarial studies every four
or five years
that review the underlying assumptions
and there were changes in the underlying
assumptions for instance
and these assumptions what Drive the
contribution rates and and the estimates
of how long it takes to pay off their
underfunding we reduce the
expected investment return twice since
then it was eight it's now 6.25 which is
more realistic given the markets these
days we also changed some demographics
in terms of expected payroll growth
especially amongst teachers that's a
cohort that's not growing as fast as it
was anticipated when when this plan
first went into place in its future
growth and payroll on which the
contributions are paid that are part
part of on paying down the underfunding
so market and changes in Actuarial
assumptions are why the
um
the the underfunding is
a larger dollar amount close to the
dollar amount it was 10 years ago but as
a percentage it's the underfunding ratio
is much lower
because again when you change those
underlying assumptions you're increasing
your liabilities
yeah
I'll just caveat by saying I'm a lawyer
not an actuarian I usually try to stay
away from the math but
representative lilac
thank you Mr chairman
I try to read the retirement system
report every year and I see the the
Investments that you have and I see
very few of them have much of a return
and then at the bottom it says assumed
rate six and a half percent
but when you add them up it's far lower
but you never publish the actual return
Why Not unless it happens to be 29 most
the time you leave it blank
respectfully sir that's incorrect we're
required by the government Accounting
Standards Board to prepare an annual
report and where we do break down our
investment returns by asset class by
investment managers over time
we also
and give the overall that's incorrect
sir there's a bottom line on that every
year in the report we also have uh
monthly meetings with our Board of
Trustees in the state of investment
Affairs is done at each of those
meetings and materials are publicly
available on our website that show month
to month what our investment returns are
broken down and in the aggregate
I'll have to get out the report you'll
have to show it to me it's not on the
same page I'd be happy to do that
further questions
oh um
thank you for your testimony
you're welcome sorry I got distracted I
did too no problem
Catherine heck
good afternoon again committee members
for the record my name is Catherine Heck
from The New Hampshire Municipal
Association and I will be incredibly
brief and that we support this
legislation and the long-term goal that
it will achieve and I think
representative Edwards
um already testified already captured
all of my testimony in that as the
faster we pay this down the large
percentage is 75 percent we're going to
see maybe not in the next two years it
won't be an immediate response to our
local taxation but over time we're going
to watch the rates go down and that will
be a savings to municipalities and
therefore a savings to our taxpayers so
I think you captured all that and how
you described it sir so I won't I'll
waste the committee's time do you have
any questions for me any questions from
the committee
yes we're good thank you thank you sir
and representative McGuire
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan McGuire I represent the town of
Epsom and I'm a supporter of this and
co-sponsor of this bill maybe I'll start
by answering representative Mooney's and
and representative Edwards questions so
I think representative Mooney asked for
sort of a specific example of how the
bill would work
let's suppose that for the biennium the
general fund is three and a half billion
dollars
okay
the bill
would take effect if the rainy day fund
is a tenth of that or higher so if it's
350 million dollars in the rainy day
fund or more
then the then the if the bill would
would act
okay that's that's lines uh 16 and so on
also if the unfunded liability is
exhausted then line 19 says the bill
would not take effect right so this only
would would happen if we have a very
healthy rainy day fund 350 million
dollars in this example right and we
have a surplus
so if we have a surplus where that
Surplus would be going into the rainy
day fund this would redirect three
quarters of it to the retirement fund to
pay off the unfunded liability
okay
so in some sense you can think of this
as a slow acting version of house bill
50. because this does help both state
taxpayers and municipalities much more
municipalities than State because it
reduces their debts so
um of of the totality of employee of
government employees in the state if I
remember the numbers right the state
employs 17 percent and municipalities
including teachers and so on employ 83
percent right so of the unfunded the
unfunded liability is one giant blob for
everybody it's not
we don't think of it as so much as the
state's responsibility and so much as
this particular
municipality's responsibility and so on
it's a total unfunded liability so when
we put money into it we help all of
those Employers in a sense equally okay
all right
now let me go into the specifics of why
we need this and I handed out two pieces
of paper that look like giant
spreadsheets
um because as an engineer I like numbers
so let's start with the one that says
2021 at the top okay
so this is I got this from Mr Carlin of
the retirement system just recently
and this shows what the what the current
unfunded liability is so if you look at
the line that starts 2022 and look over
it's uaal that's that's the unfunded
liability is currently uh
5.723 billion dollars okay and this
shows this document purports to show how
that's going to change over time
so
um
this is a prediction of what's going to
happen all right and as we all know
predictions are really difficult
especially about the future so
um
so look at so it you know it looks this
looks accurate right it's black and
white it's got four digits of of numbers
on everything and and it looks like we
will be nicely slowly reducing the
unfunded liability down to zero when we
get to 2043 or 2041 or whatever it is
but what what thanks to Mr Hoffman I
found or we found he found is the page
that starts 2007 the other page
so that's what this is the equivalent
piece of paper that was given to the
legislature in 2007 when we decided to
do something about the unfunded
liability
okay so it's the same sort of thing if
you look at it 2008 the unfunded
liability we slide over there uaal
beginning of year uh 2 billion 2.4
billion dollars
okay
and you're gonna you're gonna see what
we just heard that it's projected to go
up and a bit right it goes up a bit and
it goes if you look down that column
it's supposed to Peak at looks like
3.137 billion dollars in 2024 and then
by the time it gets to 2039 it's back
down to zero
okay
so how does that purport with what we
know now know happened in those
intervening years so let's look at
um year 13 on this 2007 page which is
2022.
right so what this page says said to the
legislature in those days was that
today's unfunded liability would be by
their predictions
3.125 billion dollars
well we now know it's not it's
5.723 billion dollars
okay those two numbers are not very
close
um and so
it's very tough making a prediction and
in and on top of that
I went to the
um the pension uh overview hearing that
the Edna committee had that was where
that where uh Mr Carlin of the
retirement system gave a summary of how
the pension system works and he said
something in that hearing that I thought
was very profound he said he was asked
why do we have this problem right where
did this unfunded liability come from so
even the people that had this unfunded
liability thought maybe we'll get up to
the three billion dollar Mark and then
we'll start coming back right so why are
we at 5 billion and what he said was I
thought was pretty profound it was about
about
um he said one of the problems is when
you give the legislature a set of
choices
they're going to pick the cheapest one
okay so they didn't do back in those
days and and through the present we
didn't do maybe the smartest thing we
did at every step of the way the
cheapest
thing right because we have we have a
lot of incentive to keep taxes low
right and so what happened was
the cheapest thing didn't turn out to be
the best it it turned out to be there's
some some sort of Rosy uh expectations
so for example uh let's just look at
payroll for example if you look on that
same line line 13 on the page 2007
it it expected that today we would have
the total government payroll of
4.249 billion dollars right but if we
look at today's picture on on the other
page our current payroll is 3.049
billion dollars you see what I mean so
in those days they expected that payroll
was going to be going up add infinitum
if you look at the bottom of that 2007
page they expected that by 2039 payroll
will be almost nine billion dollars
so that they thought a lot of people are
going to be employed and a lot of people
are going to be dumping money into the
system well that's not happening right
they didn't know that
um we're going to level off on
unemployment they didn't know that uh
kids are not going to be born and
therefore we don't need quite so many
teachers and all that sort of stuff so
um so those predictions are very very
difficult and haven't come true and so
what that means is
we ought to be paying off the the
liability the the faster we pay it off
the less we rely on unreliable
predictions
all right and and what is the what is
this unfunded liability this unfunded
liability is something that this
Committee in my experience tries to
avoid which is which is borrowing for
current expenses
right we we always want to pay our
current expenses and not put him into
debt okay but that's effectively what
we've done here because the benefits
that employees earn that's a current
expense so what actually happened was in
the past we had we had a lot of
government employees and we didn't
adequately fund their benefits
and we borrowed it we we have we owe it
it's the it's the unfunded liability
all right and it's much more this this
5.7 billion dollars all of the other
state debt is about 1.2 billion dollars
you add up all of our state bonds and
all that stuff it's minor compared to
this number
so this number needs to be brought down
as quickly as possible
um and and House Bill 555 is a is a baby
step in in that direction
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
representative Edwards
the first one is uh definitional I I
want to understand the unfunded
liability is is the unfunded liability
that's in this uh column on uh unfunded
Bill unfunded liability beginning of the
year that column is that does that
number represent
the current year payments for pensions
that are already being paid out or does
that represent sort of uh you know like
you would on a a balance sheet you'd put
a liability down that you have to
amortize over time and it's a it's more
of a a paper number than it is a cash
basis number
thank you for the question
representative and it is more of the
second than it is of the first so so the
unfunded liability also itself depends
on a lot of predictions right it
predicts
how many people are going to be in the
system over time how long are they going
to stay what benefits are they going to
earn and also how much money as as uh
the chairman pointed out how much of
income is the is the assets of the funds
going to receive over time right so we
assume in law so first of all we don't
even ask an actuary to predict what what
income we're going to have we assume in
law that our income is going to average
6.75 percent per year in Maine they
assume 6.5 percent they're more
conservative in Maine than we are here
in New Hampshire in that respect
follow up yeah follow up so there's like
two or three questions in there that I'd
want to ask you but I'll take those
offline
um
the if I can remember them but uh what
what I'd like to know now is back to the
issue of Precedence
you know like for example if this bill
becomes law
and a future legislature ends up with an
economic crisis where revenues don't
come in as projected and we have to use
the rainy day fund for what we need the
rainy day fund for
uh
is that a year that the advance payments
are held in advance that we don't that
we we that is a year that we don't
contribute any money towards the
unfunded liability under this bill is
that is that accurate essentially yes
thank you so suppose our the rainy day
fund was at 350 million yeah right and
and for the past few couple of years we
had been putting extra into the
retirement system and all of a sudden a
new big 150 million dollar debt comes
along I believe what happened in the
case you were talking about is it was
explicitly taken out of the rainy day
fund so the rainy day fund for this new
150 million dollar debt
expense would now be 200. all right so
then none of this would happen until
boom boom boom it got back up to the 350
level
right and then
and then more money could be used for
the retirement system so the political
scenario there is any time we dipped
into the rainy day fund it would be
arguably true that we've increased
property taxes by not allowing the the
balance to be decreased thereby
decreasing the contributions of the town
if if we dip into the rainy day fund
there's a good argument that we are not
meeting our obligations to reducing
property taxes
yeah I guess that's that's a little bit
of a step of us you know
a stretch because
um
currently in under current law
we are not putting any extra into the
into the retirement system right so by
doing this sometimes we would be putting
extra into the retirement system so the
retirement system will under this bill
will never be worse off than under
current law right and so it's hard to
say sometimes you're helping out
property taxpayers by reducing their
debt sometimes you're not well you know
they're not worse off by that method I'm
thinking too far ahead I'm wondering
what the next broken promise is is yeah
thank you
all right further questions
alrighty thank you representative thank
you
any further discussion
in that case I'll close the hearing
members of the fiscal committee we're
going to meet across the hall
for a pre-fiscal meeting for tomorrow's
meeting
can you show me where
it does thank you yeah I looked at I
looked at one online a year or two ago
this this is your this is the summary
all right so I should look for the
summary